representative M if you give him the
floor first on it and he moves for inter
study that would
bypass right you let him make the first
motion well I'm just trying to work
something here he wants he's suggesting
interim
study
Harvey
Bia
I
is
house all right is are we ready or House
Bill
170 oh yeah call rise for the salute to
the
flag would you all please join with me
in a pledge to our flag I pledge to the
flag of the United States of America and
to the rep which one nation God
indivisible
with okay like to call the meeting to
order on
uh the executive session on House Bill
1709 9
Kelly speak uh and for for a motion
thank you Mr chair is the motion of
ought to pass still on the table from
from last session why don't we start it
over okay just say just just make the
motion of ought to pass and then we'll
go to the amendment okay I will make a
motion of ought to pass on House Bill
1709 is there a second second f
representative
Darby uh we wish this uh do you have an
amendment I do I would like to introduce
um house uh amendment number 2024 0686
H and I moveed to pass as amended is
there a second to the
amendment representative veils seconds
the amendment you wish to speak on the
amendment yes sir I would be happy
to so the the amendment um addresses a
number of the concerns that were raised
at last week's executive
session um primarily it removes section
three of the bill which was the section
dealing with the language around
795 um the the other um the other
concerns that were raised by the
committee um were the house a number of
house members that were on that served
on this commission um that has been
increased from 2 to
4 um the and it also um changes a bit of
the language and what the commission
will be looking
at um to include um aspects around
Recreation conservation and the
protection of undeveloped land um or any
other
um that the committee sees fit to
discuss around the issue of forest
carbon the the um
it fixes the spelling errors that were
pointed out and the um issues with
chaptering that were pointed out last
week and then it also
um softens the the the the shall report
it says shall report any findings if
necessary
um any recommended legislation to the
legislature and that report would go to
committee there you wish to speak on
your uh wish to speak on your
second no that covers it for me thank
you
okay representative Darby to speak on
the amendment thank you Mr chair yes I
just wanted to um concur with
representative Kelly um the amendment I
really focuses on the core concerns that
were raised um in the at the work
session specifically um it takes out the
language about current about studying
current use and recognizes that current
use and uh and carbon credit programs
are really separate issues it also like
representative Kelly said uh addresses
the issue with 795 which is potential
taxation of um un un UNH harvested land
um and is waiting for the uh Dr study
that was recommended in um House Bill
1697 1679 from uh t& that will be voted
on probably next week in the floor
lastly um to account for the concerns
about the uh the number of um of
legislators on the committee um this
amendment adds two additional house
members to really uh uh even that out
while still um providing a lot um
significant uh expertise from uh various
uh various uh stakeholder committees so
um you know really having spent a a lot
of time with stakeholders on this over
the last week or so um I believe that
this addresses the concerns of the uh
the primary concerns of most of the
stakeholders and uh and would recommend
passage of the amendment thank
amendment represent representative
W um thank you Mr
chairman I have
been totally confused on this bill and
what it does and I've spoken to all
kinds of people I think that I can live
with a commission now which will start
to study this thing and bring it
together um I was very very conflicted
in trying to
keep anybody happy on this thing and at
least I think I can keep myself happy by
voting for this
Commission
anyone else wish to speak on the uh on
amendment seeing
none on the amendment will the clerk
please call a
rooll yes thank you on the
amendment uh for
yes representative
Harrington yes
yes uh the clerk votes yes
representative Healey yes representative
wolf representative McHugh no
representative Donnelly
yes representative Dunn
yes representative
Vale yes representative brong yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Simpson yes representative Drew
fox fox fox I'm sorry
yes yes thank you sorry about that
representative Fox
um uh representative Darby point point
of
order you said uh Amendment on 1709 but
I want to be clear with voting on 06
86h yes thank you yes I vote Yes okay
thank you for the clarification yes uh
representative hoit
yes representative lontine yes
representative lit yes representative
Ryan yes and the
chair yes that is 18 yeses one no motion
passes okay 18 or 19 I'm sorry 19 I was
looking at the
bottom 19 to1 motion
passes
okay we have to we that we had to vote
for the on the motion of ought ought to
amended you would what you made that
motion that was seconded by
representative
Darby do we have discussion do we to
discuss on the motion on out to pass as
amended
yes thank you Mr chair I will just be
voting no on this as it is not
recommended at this time by the
Hampshire Timberlands
Association um Timberland Owners
Association and as
being um not needed and also it's may be
a small matter but it doesn't list a uh
a landowner as one of the designes it
does have a member of the public on here
but that doesn't specify that it's a
landowner smallish but I'll be voting no
thank you repres representative
Kelly thank you Mr chair um to to
address to um representative Harvey buia
concerns um the public member of the
current use board a public member
there's three public members to the
board two of the three members are have
to be current use land owners the all
three are currently land owners
Timberland or owners of of current use
land the the that my is that that public
member of the current use board is is
meant to be a stand in for a um a land
owner themselves and uh the the um I I
understand where the
um the talk around 697 in this
commission um comes from and I would say
that the the
1697 does a very specific thing it
releases a report this November um in
discussions with numerous people on this
subject this commission doesn't Begin
work until the following year taking
into account that report um the
solutions that are going to be necessary
will be something that has to be
designed by a group um the it we
shouldn't just take
dr's um prescription we should take a a
look at this and let a diverse group of
stakeholders come together and hopefully
put together something is um
comprehensive so the the I I will be
voting yes and I would hope others would
St thank you Mr chairman um I'm voting
in favor of the ought to pass as amended
um I think that when we first had the
topic of carbon credits and how they're
going to affect lifestyles in New
Hampshire whether it be working or
recreating that um we brought this in
and now we are looking at a commission
that will hopefully bring us a lot more
expertise and help us to respond to the
Advent of carbon credits and in the
context of State
lands so this is an opportunity for us
to get ahead if possible and I think the
commission will be a popular Commission
help representa
representative the
Q thank you Mr
chairman so this this commission and
this bill as it is is anything but
popular when the state Forester director
of division enforcement lands opposes it
New Hampshire Timberland owners oppose
it in its current form in at at the way
we just amended it they oppose it
no other stakeholders support this those
are the stakeholders those are the
experts we have no business binding a
future legislature by passing a
commission now that doesn't take effect
for two
years that's
ridiculous right there's plenty of time
to look at the report from 1697 that
passed unanimously out of scitec they'll
issue a report in no report in November
we can interim study this
now and take a look at it in November or
a future legislature can easily create
this Commission in five
minutes right but when I hear from the
key experts and I hear from our own
group here that some of the members are
confused on this we should not be
passing this commission that doesn't
take effect until two years when the key
stakeholders tell us they're perfectly
happy with 1697 the work it does they're
a little happier with this amendment
that the current use part is out but
there are still two members from the
current use board on this
commission we should re
re-refer this bill for interim study so
if we could make that motion I'd be
happy to make it I don't know whether
no is there any other members of let see
representative Darby you had your hand
up did you
not h
l referring to me thank you
representative who are you referring
to representative
Lon Oh I thought you were but I know you
you don't look alike I
believe who is it you want go ahead yeah
thank you a
gentleman representative L thank
you I I think we have no idea the impact
of carbon credits
coming coming our way and I think it
could be enormous I do think it's
important that we start studying it and
this just sets up to take the
information from the bill that came out
of Science and Technology and be
prepared to study it um I I think it's
tremendously important and we we we
don't know it's the stakeholders Beyond
who come to the state house it's
everyone's whose lives are very much
ected by the timber industry in those
communities up north and I think we
should be prepared we're not enacting
any law we're just getting set up to do
the work and study this important issue
so I'm going to vote for
it okay represent representative
wolf um I'm going to vote for this
because yes it doesn't start for two
years or a year and a half whever but it
sets it up we got the other Bill coming
forward we should have answers uh after
November it puts us in place and I
absolutely Echo everything that
representative L montine said that we
need to be in place to move this rather
than
waiting till next session of the
legislature if something happens we can
kill this bill next time in the
legislature but we have it in place and
important
pardon repres representative uh
Rong thank you Mr chair I agree with um
representative lontine and
representative wolf that it is important
to study this before this bill came
before us I don't know about you but I
didn't know anything about these carbon
credits or the extent that they play a
role in our state and I think it's
imperative that we study this more we
get the key stakeholders together I mean
when I look at the the opening section
of the bill it says there is established
a commission to study the effect of
forest carbon programs on local tax
revenue and the Legacy Timber industry
that's incredibly incredibly important
for us to do and when we look at their
objectives uh to to study the effective
Forest carbon programs possible
alternative Revenue sources for towns
that account for net imp to the local
economy you know in the other four areas
they're looking at that's our
responsibility to make sure these things
are addressed and I think having people
together from diverse stakeholder groups
to look at it is is going to be very
important and to Mr mcu's point that in
in the future we could set this up in
five minutes we've already been
discussing this for about 10 or 15
minutes so I think it's time that we
just move this forward get it in place
so that when we do have further
um information this commission can hit
the ground running thank
you representative Derby thank you Mr
chair um members of this uh committee
received emails from both um the nhtoa
as well as this morning um Mr Hackley um
nhtoa um reported three concerns that
they had um related to 795 they referred
to it as Timber taxation current use
references in what was going to be
studied as well as transparency they
were specifically referring to um the um
the deed the um the deed language so um
uh and um Mr Hackley uh responded and
said I agree with nhtoa basically um so
let me I'll just repeat sort of what I
said apologies for the repetition here
but this amendment actually addresses
the concerns of nhtoa the Timber tax
thing gone the current use references
gone now the transparency uh I think
that's honestly a a an incorrect label
for the issue um the uh it's talking
about whether or not the the the
language says should um should carbon
credit programs be recorded on the deed
to determine that there's some concern
that some of these not always but
sometimes those um carbon credit
programs um are com uh carry with the
property if it's with the property you
know it seems reasonable that um the
deed is an appropriate place to record
that we don't know that's why this
that's why the commission needs to study
and that's why that language wasn't
removed but to be clear there were three
issues two of them are addressed one of
them needs to be studied um the uh Mr
Hackley said I agree with I have the
same concerns and and they're addressed
So otpa based on the amendment we just
passed is appropriate thank
you
repr thank you just responding to what
Mrs rung said um nhtoa does not support
this neither does the D the director
from preservation of forests and and the
director that representative Derby just
mentioned so if we think those experts
if we know if if we think we know better
than those experts that this committee
is tasked to work with that's a shame
because they've studied this at
length we have another bill that is
already passed this commission doesn't
take effect for two
years right and the stakeholders the
experts have told
us they don't want this in its current
form this morning in real time so I
caution all of you to think if you know
better than the experts then then pass
it and we've heard it clearly stated
that the stakeholders opposed this
bill repres representative wolf for a
second time I don't believe and maybe we
should ask that anybody has seen this
amendment because it just came down
today this
morning so I don't know
that and I won't ask but I just got it
this morning I don't know how anybody
else got it earlier
so this addresses the concerns that I
yesterday all
Bale thank you I just have one final
statement um and that's just that when
you get a number of emails from really
invested stakeholders you have people
who are willing to work on the
commission I feel that people will come
forward that have an interest in the
stakeholders and we need to believe in
the communities that support us and
involve them and I do think that this um
bill as amended really involves people
that need to be in the know and that
have so much expertise to contribute
because the best legislation comes from
opinion I have a question of
Representative
Kelly
Kelly there's a line on item 21 says the
first meeting of the commission shall be
held before July 31st
2025 I read that to mean that this this
this is not
this is the time that you meeting has to
be started it can be started any time
before that so knowing how commissions
are set up and how long it takes to get
members on a
commission this is not a Comm commission
that is going to be have going to occur
in two years this is a commission that's
going to occur as soon as it's possible
and it recognizes
that I re I I'm reading this to mean
that the the two-year rule is not is is
was in the origin other amendments but
do not exist not there anymore in fact
it says November 1st of
two I'm reading was
representative Kelly yeah to answer your
question Mr chair so section two of the
bill is the repeal so section one of the
bill would take effect January 31st of
2025 so less than a year from now the
commission could be established from
that point forward so between January
31st of next year and July 31st of next
year the commission meet have their
first meeting I believe that there's a
at that point we will have enough data
um from the
1697 um Bill to start to have those
discussions I believe that you correct
that there are people who are extremely
motivated to talk about this issue and
so there will be it will me the
commission will likely meet long before
that July 31st date correct thank
you representative representative M mchu
Mr chairman you mentioned earlier the
importance of keeping this bill uh
keeping this subject matter under the
purview of this committee and I agree
with
you would it not be kept under the
purview of this committee with unlimited
public participation from any part of
the public any stakeholder in fact if it
were re-referred that's a just a
question to the chair could could we not
re-refer it keep it here within our
purview which is what you stated was a
priority and several other members have
as
well and and of course doesn't the chair
have the ability to caucus State I
stated that yes so wish you wish to talk
about what happened in caucus stated it
here was a priority to keep it within
the subject matter experts so I haven't
spoken on that but go right ahead well I
I I believe it's important to keep it
within the subject matter exports and
and pay attention to the composition of
the board and my suggestion is we could
in fact keep it
here clarify the the dates of
implementation maybe maybe implement it
sooner so we don't you know in in in
January
of anytime anytime sooner if we kept it
here I don't want to get into an uh back
and forth with you how the the what we
need to do is go on with with the go I
cannot stop a mo a motion in the mid the
in mid motion this is just discussion of
the mo of a motion there is a motion
before us the proper procedure is to for
the motion to be defeated if the if uh
and
that's that's where we go otherwise I
have no authority to to pull pull a
motion back from the from the from once
it's in front of the committee would a
motion to table be in order uh no there
you cannot table in committee uh
representative Al montain do you want
have a
question and unfortunate by the way
unfortunately there's in committee you
can't call a question
either
will uh yeah I just want to make one
more comment I think by setting up uh
this commission that does include
members of this committee we are still
keeping it in committee but I think the
things that have to be studied are very
Broad and will take a lot of time that
members of this committee will not be
able to do all that work on their own
commission representative dun for the
first time yes thank you thank you for
the question
um we talked a lot about stakeholders
I've talked to the representatives from
the North Country they are stakeholders
in this they're they represent people
from the North Country they support this
so if we're concerned about stakeholders
the North Country Representatives
bill seeing no one
else on motion about to pass as amended
role on a to pass as amended House Bill
1709 representative harb
yes representative Harrington
yes representative Horgan yes clerk
votes no representative Healey
yes okay representative wolf
yes representative MCU
no representative Donnelly yes
representative dun
yes representative veale yes
representative rung
yes representative
Kelly
yes representative Simpson yes
representative Fox yes representative
Darby yes representative
hoit yes representative ltin yes
representative lit yes representative
Ryan yes
and the chair yes that is 18 to one
motion
go
consent no I think it has a financial FN
designation anyway so well it does but
the B as amended
so no but I can have a Minority Report
is yeah is there going to be a Minority
Report yeah okay
uh this has to be representative Kelly
the report has to be in by noon time
today that that uh that I was just
informed that by uh by the committee
researcher that uh there I thought it
was for by him by tomorrow but I was
with City researcher informed me that
the uh it's for it is today so by noon
time so please have it in even if you
even if you just go in the office and
start while we doing the other stuff all
right now let the next
1142 you want
that okay we going to open the executive
session on House Bill
1142 and give the floor to
representative Derby I believe you have
a motion you'd like to move no he has an
amendment uh I need you need a mo you
need a motion on the you need a motion
on the bill uh you don't want to make a
motion I'll make I'll make the I'll I'll
make the
motion I'll recognize uh the chair
representative Rulo uh motion ought to
pass motion off to pass do we have a
second second who was that uh
representative
dun representative dun
second I'll recognize uh representative
Darby you have a motion to make um thank
you Mr Vice chair I yes I'd like to um
make uh amend House Bill 1142 with
Amendment
2024 d06
53h do we have a second on that
motion
I'll second it seconded by
representative Dunn representative Darby
you want to speak on your motion um yes
um thank
you um this motion is uh based on
discussion um that we had at the sorry
this um amendment is based on discussion
that we had at the hearing um followed
on by a an amendment by representative
makoni as well as testimony submitted by
um by Mr trobridge um in a letter by um
commissioner Scott um what we heard was
that um the there was some concern about
um the length of time um the
qualifications to retake the test um and
this amendment
um provides uh rul making for um Dees to
determine how the um what what those
requirements are whether it's work
whether it's work whether it's um
training or other uh recommend other um
other qualifications in order to retake
the test um this amendments in both the
septic designer program and septic
installer program that involve rules the
test of course um the requirements to
retake the test but as well as other um
uh requirements in terms of um licenses
being uh revoked and um fees and things
like that um and uh providing Dees Ru
making Authority for these these
comprehensive programs I believe is
appropriate and so just to summarize
this um this incorporates language from
um suggested by representative makoni as
well as the rul making language uh
requested by Department of Environmental
Services so I urge you uh to pass uh
this amendment thank you thank you any
further discussion on the
amendment representative run thank you
Mr
chair um initially when this bill was
brought forward and and even with the
amendment I thought it was a great idea
but subsequent to the public hearing we
received a letter from a Mr Spalding who
is in this business and he raised some
concerns to me that make me feel as
though this bill and the amendment are
not ready for prime time I didn't
realize and and I don't know if it would
be appropriate for Mr trobridge to
address us but that there there there
likely exists a disconnect between the
course that's used to prepare the
examinees for the test and the actual
test that the test doesn't reflect the
course material and that may be the
reason for um the high failure rate not
the lack of experience in the field and
the course is developed I believe it's
delivered by an outside organization but
Dees ad ad ministers the test um I would
like us to defeat the amendment and
ought to pass as amended so that we can
move to have an interim study because in
all of this we have never had a
discussion about the course and that
seems to be a very integral part into
the certification of the
examinees thank you any further yes
representative Donnelly thank you Mr
chair um the amendment um that's been
presented before us uh it seems a I
think about driver's licenses and we
give people three chances before they
have to go back into doing studies I
think this is a little too restrictive
day any further discussion on the
amendment first first Mr
chair uh I wasn't when the amend
Amendment uh came out I did contact
representative
mcon and he uh he liked he he approved
of the the
representatives representative Darby's
Amendment uh
also in speaking with this
uh on a memo that
we received in yesterday afternoon from
Mr
Spalding complaining about the quality
of the
tests this I'm I'm told that by the uh
committee researcher that this actually
you can't even put this information into
the file because it came after the
hearing this I hold this to be a the
same thing that you were if you were at
a a wedding and the preacher says Speak
now or forever hold your peace somebody
running down the aisle says stop go back
forget about
this well no you have a chance to come
before this committee and testify so we
can ask you the
questions the fact that you didn't do it
I'm sorry I'm not I I'll listen to what
you have to say but it's not going to be
determinative as far as how I vote so uh
I I look at it for what it is it's some
it's you're late sorry now I why should
we hold up the uh the rest of hold up
the the rest of us
for fact that somebody was out of town
when they uh when this was
held thank you any other discussion
first time no first time as
representative run thank you Mr chair I
totally appreciate that uh chairman Rulo
um I agree with you the frustration but
um it's not always easy for people to
know what we're doing up here um it's
and there were some issues raised
regarding the contracted course also
that many of the septic designers and
installers that we would expect to hire
these people who failed the test um
they're really one or two man shops and
they may not have the the payroll to
support an extra person um if if we
can't put the breakes on I mean I still
support an interterm study but perhaps
if we could at least recess the
executive session on this like we did
for um representative Kelly's bill um
just it would give me some time to get
further educated on these issues and see
if there is some uh credibility to them
um I would also like to follow up with
Mr trobridge about some of the claims
made in that Spalding letter but I I
don't know if if you would be amenable
to just you know having us deal with
this next time when I feel more
take
thank you for your comments
representative
Vale thank you Mr chairman I will be
voting for The ought to pass as amended
and um just simply I think we need to
get more people out there and hopefully
improve the rate of passing so that we
have this resource in our state we do
need we need people in every industry um
and we certainly need
people in the septic installing industry
things are behind and we do want to get
people certified to design um so I will
be voting on to pass as amended thank
you thank you any other
comments representative Darby M we're
still talking about the amendment right
the
amendment
yeah any more discussion on the
amendment saying thenone I'll ask the
clerk to read the r
thank you very much uh on the amendment
of
0653 Representative harb yes ought to
pass uh representative Harrington yes
representative Horgan yes clerk votes
yes representative Healey yes
representative wolf yes representative
McHugh yes representative Donnelly
no representative Dunn
yes okay representative Vale yes
representative rung
no representative
Kelly yes representative Simpson yes
representative Fox yes representative
Derby yes representative
hoit yes representative lontine yes
representative lit yes representative
Ryan Yes representative the chair
yes okay that is
18-2 motion passes got that one right so
motion thank you Mr chair I would like
to make a motion ought to pass as
amended uh on uh what is this 11:42
house b 11:42 as amended I'll second
that who's second
second
discussion on ought to pass is
amended representative Simpson did you
want to say something I didn't catch you
before thank you Mr chair I was actually
um raising my hand to make sure to move
it or to Second it but I am but I am
happy to say that I think it we have in
so many fields we have on on uh on the
ground experience as part of training
and I think that hands-on experience um
in in
many fields I hesitate to say every is
really really um important and so I'm
glad that we're um giving this uh doing
this hopefully um making this
opportunity available to um those who
will be in the field of septic so thank
you thank you comments on the motion
ought to pass as amended representative
rang thank you Mr chair yeah I still I
still have concerns with this um we
could have somebody working in the field
which I think is a is a great
opportunity I agree with representative
Simpson um I'm not sure we have the
capacity in to hire these people with
the existing installers and designers
who are out there and I I think
Representative donelly makes a great
point that if they fail it's just going
to prolong the ability for them to take
the test and then primarily I don't know
anything about this course until I read
Mr Spalding's letter and I know that um
representative Hoy had also um as a
certified installer he is aware that you
know there is a disconnect between the
course and a test I just feel we're
pushing this on thinking that it's going
to solve a problem and I I would really
regret if that happened and we found out
we're in the same boat we are in two
years so I I would prefer I'm not going
to vote otpa I I'm hoping it fails so
that I can introduce a motion for
interim study thank you thank thank you
any more discussion on otpa
representative Darby thank you Mr chair
I I share um representative Run's
concerns about the test um not only what
we heard in the letter that was that was
sent to the committee but also from
other Representatives that have taken
the um the septic system installer test
in the past and um
and reflected on similar challenges I
really hope that um that Dees uh listens
to this feedback and evaluates the
alignment between the um the the
coursework the opportunities to train
for this and the test itself um because
they the the pass rate on the test is
abysmal it was reported as abysmal both
by the prime sponsor as well as by Dees
and um I I believe that uh training um
that training on the job training of
course is an is a critical aspect of it
but um there's also other aspects of it
that need to be that need to come into
play however um we also heard that um
there are limited spots for the test um
people that retake and continue to fail
are um taking up those spots and um and
that there's a real problem that needs
to be solved that I believe will be
addressed by this
bill that is the reason why um as was uh
represented in testimony described in
testimony that Dees um went to uh
representative mcon to begin with to
start this process I think it's a fair
step forward I think there's more to do
but I um urge a to pass as amended thank
you any further discussion
representative wolf you're raising your
hand yes sir go ahead thank you Mr chair
I Echo representative Darby's comments
because I think unless we start to move
this forward and I'm hoping that Dees
has heard loud and clear our concerns it
won't change and I agree that it should
be studied more but I think we need to
move it forward to get those people in
there and then if we need to amend it in
the future we will if Dees hasn't hurt
us when this committee reconveyance so
I'm going to vote for
discussion did you want to say no no I
want
uh the chair wants to just make a
comment about testing and Publishing I
remember during the hearing they
mentioned that questions that wouldn't
appear on the exam were published so
people could see it uh reading the
amendment and looking at the law I think
the disconnect if there is one can be
corrected outside of this amendment I
don't think it's impossible to
coordinate
testing um I'm a licensed attorney and
we can look at the tests from prior
years and then we have online testing uh
but the testing can be coordinated I
think in the the test itself with the
department so I think that issue can be
resolved outside of this amendment so
I'm going to support the amendment based
upon the other testimony we did have
during the hearing just thought I'd put
that out there and since I was the last
one to speak I'll ask the clerk to read
thank you very much um representative
harb yes representative Harrington yes
representative Horgan yes CL votes yes
representative Healey yes representative
wolf yes representative MCU yes
representative Donnelly yes
representative dun yes representative
Vale yes representative rung no
representative Kelly yes representative
Simpson yes yes representative Fox yes
representative Darby yes representative
po
no representative lontine yes
representative lit yes representative
Ryan
yes and the chair yes and that is 18-2
motion
passes majority report representative
report thank
you still need that by noon by noon time
all right
today
yeah what time is
not so I'm going to close the executive
session on
11:42 and in a moment we'll move forward
right
ready give you I'll accept the pink
go
thank
down
good
all
right like to reopen the hearing or
actually start the hearings on today's
agenda U so pardon for
the for about being late on House Bill
1268 relative to prohibiting the
issuance of large groundwater withdrawal
permits for the commercial sale of
bottle or bulk water uh representative
uh
yours good morning Mr chair and uh good
morning members of the resource
Recreation committee the record uh I'm
Tony Kaplan representative of the towns
of hener Bradford and Warner a MAAC 8
and here to talk about House Bill 1268
on L large groundwater withdrawals for
the purpose of a bottle or bulk
water and the idea is to prohibit large
extractions of over 57,000 gallons in a
24-hour period of uh groundwater the
reason for that reason to want to uh
prohibit these groundwater extractions
and and protect the groundwater resource
is uh twofold first off we see that
around the country um groundwater is
being pressured under pressure from
industrial uh industrial extractions
there's private Equity firms that are
buying up bottled of water companies
such as uh you know Poland Springs in
our neighbor State of Maine and Deer
Park others uh and the what these
private Equity firms do their business
model is to try to extract profit from
these companies uh and how they do that
is by pumping up the amount of water
that they pump and uh you know bottling
more water and selling more water so
that's putting groundwater uh reserves
Under Pressure around the
country um the other thing is climate
change uh with a warming climate uh we
see that we're more prone to Drought as
uh matter of fact in the last 20 years
in New Hampshire 11 of them have been
drought
years uh and even with the increased
rain you know the uh intense rains that
we see uh what happens is that rain just
just washes off the surface doesn't
really soak into the aquifer so uh
another reason to want to protect
groundwater is uh the threat of climate
change um so also the the growth of the
bottle water industry is problematic in
itself uh plast the use of plastic to to
make these bottles uh you know it takes
2,000 times more energy to make a bottle
of water than it does just to use the
tap water so you know that's that's a
threat again to the to the environments
that climate change becomes like a
vicious cycle of course you know
threatens the it threatens the climate
which again is threatening the
groundwater so
uh and a lot of the plastic waste ends
up in in landfills I think the estimate
is something like 86% of the plastic
bottles end up uh you know just trashed
in our landfills we see the bottles on
the side of the roads all the time just
being you know thrown out uh and if uh
if they end up in incinerators the you
know that's problematic in terms of the
air emissions and the the Hazardous
wayte getting into the ash which ends up
in landfills and into the groundwater
again as it leeches out of the landfill
so uh so it's just it's a problematic
industry in itself um so that's the idea
that that's the idea I'm hoping that you
see it my way and and uh would seek to
protect this the precious resource uh
that we need municipalities depend on it
for their drinking water uh private
homeowners depend on it um what what
happens with the groundwater extraction
if it if it gets too problematic there's
not a lot of research done on the
effects of uh pumping bottled water um
but we have seen in some states that you
know you you get uh obviously lowered
groundwater T lowered water table means
there's less water available for other
purposes uh there's less water into our
streams uh streams running dry Springs
running dry um and even things like land
subsidence where the land starts to sink
and in some states we're seeing that
happen uh so it's a it's a it's a public
resource should be protected and that's
what this bill intends to do so with
that I'll uh hope to take any
questions representative rung then repes
representative L
montain thank you very much very much Mr
chair and thank you representative for
taking my question um you this is such a
difficult issue because I don't think
there's any right or wrong way and I
want to give you uh an example of what's
going on in miramac and and you know ask
what your response to that would be as
you're aware we have the largest
groundwater contamination in the history
of New Hampshire with pasas and it was
discovered in
2016 there are still to this day
families in my community and represent
of hey's community who are relying on
bottled water because their tap water is
so polluted and there's disagreement
with the polluter on whether they're
going to take responsibility for that um
to put in some type of a filtration
system so would your bill prohibit the
government or communities from being
able to address those issues when we
there they are faced with an emergency
like shouldn't we have the state be able
to say we have to pull bulk water uh or
we we we have to ban this because this
groundwater is so polluted that we need
to rely on commercial water to address
it yeah that's an interesting uh you
know hypothetical um I don't think this
bill would actually put you know present
day production of bottled water out of
business and it's not going to stop it
cold you know what I mean there's
there's still going to be plenty of
bottled water uh from the just what's
out there at present uh to meet those
kind of emergency
uses um but but I think that what we're
trying to stop with this build would be
the you know continued expansion upward
of of the bottle water industry uh
because it's problematic in terms of
protecting the groundwater resource
which you know is is a precious resource
and you
know as you as you can appreciate in
marac we need to protect the groundwater
um from pollution and and from you know
it's it's just for it's for uh for what
we needed for which is public health and
and drinking water you know we need
portable drinkable water
um so yeah I mean I think it it's
bottled water is definitely necessary in
emergency situations uh like the one in
marac today and I wouldn't want to you
know obviously not stop that ability to
use bottled water for those purposes and
I don't think this bill would do that
though for a
followup um so you say you don't think
this bill would prevent that but do you
think that should be in the purview of
De yes to make that decision rather than
just say the department shall not
approve any large water groundwater
extraction do you think they might be a
better judge depending on a particular
situation whether they need to grant
that permit okay so I see what you're
saying if there was an emergency such
that we needed to pump our own water for
instance because there's no commercially
available bottle water and it was an
emergency yeah I mean that that I don't
know if if that's you know in some other
statute that an emergency power the the
state can take resources from wherever
they want basically but that might be
something to consider as an amendment
mean in your committee I mean that's
about representative Lon for a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question um I then had
the second thought that my question is
probably better suited for Dees but
maybe you could answer this question
where does the figure of
57600 gallons come from that is
something that the will be better able
to answer than I I mean it seems like
that is the upper limit of you know that
would that's what's considered a large
groundwater extraction I don't know why
is representative Derby for a question
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative Kaplan for taking my
question um we I've definitely been
reading lately about aquafers across the
country that have been decimated by over
withdrawals um the Midwest is really um
being particularly hampered by it um and
aquafers are are large they they impact
a lot more than one Community um
obviously New Hampshire has a very
different sort of climate um than the
Midwest and I'm wondering if you have
any um uh are if this is something
you're you're concerned about happening
in New Hampshire or if there's you've
seen any practical effects of large
water withdrawals um impacting you know
Community um Water
Resources yeah I mean I don't think
we're in the same thank you for the
question represent I mean we're not at
the point of you know people in the
midwest who see their aquafers is drying
up I don't think that's the situation in
New Hampshire this is intended to be
more of a forward-looking proactive
approach too to defending our our
resources I you know but I mean in terms
of the impacts uh and what the situation
is you know with our groundwater at
present I think somebody from DS might
you Brandon
Kern
yes
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the committee I'm Brandon kernin I'm the
administrator of the drinking water and
groundwater Bureau um we're here to
testify and House Bill 1268 which would
prohibit our agency from issuing a
permit for large groundwater withdrawals
that are going to be used for bottle
water or bulk water if they exceed
57,600 gallons over any 24-hour period
or that's 40 gallons a minute if you PP
pump
continuously we oppose this legislation
for a number of reasons and first of all
you know New Hampshire already has a
comprehensive permitting process in
place for large groundwater withdrawals
ensures that existing water users and
water resources and environmental
resources will not be adversely impacted
in this process issues a permit that
permit has two things associated one it
has ongoing monitoring reporting and two
it expires in 10 years we have to
reissue a permit every 10 years and so
this bill could impact a couple
facilities that have a permit that would
need a new permit every 10 years with
the permitting process and the renewal
we reassess the situation we reassess
other water users in the area that may
have developed over time we look at the
water budget to the extent climate
change is concerned we look at that and
we have been building floting into our
permits triggers that address the
droughts reoccurring droughts we've seen
lately where based on different water
level measurements or precipitation
Trends you have a variable withdrawal
rate in your permit it's just not a
one-sized fix fits-all type of permit
and so we don't think the prohibition
for um bottle water is necessary because
we have such a comprehensive um process
in place we also don't think the
legislation is needed because since the
law for large withdrawals was passed in
1998 and the rules into 2000 we have no
new operation in New Hampshire that's
relying on a large groundwater
withdrawal permit at this time and
that's for a couple of reasons one you
our our pering process is relatively
prohibitive compared to other states it
is so comprehensive but it's also costly
and timec consuming that a corporation
wanting to develop a new bottle of water
which are all printing process would go
to somewhere like New York or somewhere
where it's really easy to drill hole and
pump water without ongoing cost of
complying with a permit and that upfront
two threee permitting
process another reason I think we
haven't seen any new operations using a
large groundwater permit in our state is
that the marketplace has simply changed
you bottle water has trended towards
beverage manufacturers buying water from
municipalities and treating it
substantially and adding their own
proprietary minerals and vitamins or
what have you to it and and selling that
product opposed to the traditional
Spring Water another reason is it's just
we've seen in New Hampshire where people
land owners that have Wells have tried
to develop bottle water facilities like
breaking into the marketplace is very
difficult you have to get access to
shelf space on the supermarkets you have
to get access to the transportation
networks and the companies in the
marketplace already have those in place
and it's hard for a new independent
player to to to get get those
things we also think that a large that
the prohibition is not needed because
you know of the permits we've issued so
far in the state for bottled water which
has been um six four have never operated
never even built their facility they
obtained the permit spent all that time
and money but never found the business
planned to pan out and never actually
constructed their facility of the other
two one of them never operated on a
large scale that exceeded the permitting
threshold of 57,600 gallons they ended
up just producing small volumes of water
and selling them at local country stores
and things like that and then the six
permit is for a facility that's in
operation right now but they essenti
replace free Flowing Springs that were
grandfathered from regulation you know
so they basically could just divert the
spring into their plant and bottle that
they replace that with Wells so that
they would have you know better
protected water less susceptibility to
bacteria contamination so what I'm
saying is just we haven't really seen
the pressure for bottle water um
development in the state what we have
seen though is you know 35 new community
sources permitted under the large
withraw printing process that are active
we've also seen four golf courses um for
irrigation that have been permitted and
active so that's kind of where you know
the growth for water extraction has been
not with bottled
water I do want to point out that the
spirit of house 1268 is is kind of um
inconsistent when you think about a
technically there's lots of consumptive
uses of water out there a bottle water
really strikes people emotionally we get
calls a lot when people see a truck near
a stream or a lake filling up with water
and driving away but we don't get calls
when there's a hose thrown in a lake or
a well next to a lake and it's pumping
and irrigating a soccer field during a
drought irrigating is the same thing as
extracting water for a bottle water
you're not Wheeling the water through
the environment it's gone it's displaced
it's either going on the grass and
evaporating or it's being transpired by
vegetation and then there's other
consumptive uses you know all over the
state the state itself owns aquaculture
Farms where we're pumping from Deep
Wells right into a tank that's just
flowing away into the Watershed that's
displacement of water water you know
there's manufacturers of different
products that use water that are pumping
water and shipping it away so there's
lots of consumptive uses of water out
there Beyond bottled
water I do want to caution that although
the legislature certainly could pass a
law prohibiting proh
prohibiting use of uh of large
withdrawals for bottle water um that
could violate common law um you know the
legislature works as statutory law but
there's another body of law out there
based on Court decisions going back to
England and the colonies and then our
own country's um judicial system that
establishes that property owners have a
right to use water on their land in that
if a law is passed just taking that
right away from them without some
compelling need protecting the
environment or public health that that
could be a taking and compensation could
be required by the state or by the
property owner from the
state um one thing I do want to point
out that if this were to pass we really
need to clarify the bulk water part of
this um right now we have bulk water
being um being provided all over the
state usually from Community water
systems that contractors doing
construction maybe swimming pool
companies that fill up swimming pools or
even for Community Water Systems
emergency supplies for of water
Community water systems are relying on
tankers that carrying water from
Community water systems that have large
withrawal permits and it's not clear if
this would apply those that bulk water
situation and we'd be really worried if
it did because we really need that
emergency supply of water for Community
Water Systems when these small systems
have a well failure or a big leak and
lose a lot of water and need an outside
questions representative Rong thank you
Mr chair and thank you Mr Kel for taking
my question um getting back to the
number of uh that's the the the
permitted allowable amount it's um
57,600 gallons how was that number
derived so back in 1998 and it it holds
true today we had two sets of
regulations for Community Water Systems
when you wanted to develop a source and
for small community Water Systems things
like a Condominium Association or
something um we had one set of
regulations and then for municipal
systems we had another set of
regulations and it seemed like the
breako for those larger operations the
Community Systems versus those smaller
water systems was about 40 gallons a
minute or 57,600 gallons a day you know
essentially it was a consensus number at
the time where we had that number
already differentiating the two type of
withdrawals and for developing policy it
was thought that that would be a good
place to draw the line it's it served us
well I mean certainly there's situations
where it may not be low enough but that'
be a very localized rare situation and
there's situations where it's Overkill
where if you're in a really remote area
without a lot of other water users that
threshold is very low to require all
this work so it's it's kind of the
history of
it representative Donell thank you Mr
chair for take letting me to have this
question thank you for taking my
question um so I'm a representative from
Salem and I know that we have um
additional water source coming down uh
through the pipeline and I also
understand that there will be a mar the
marac uh Wells that are going to be
drilled or they're actually being worked
on to help increase that water source
coming down through southern New
how would this Bill affect that
particular
project to the
extent you know so right now there's
water being wheeled from Manchester
Waterworks all the way down to the state
line and so to the extent any of the
Water Systems be it Dairy plasti Salem
any a penu smaller systems want to
provide bulk water or want to allow a
new business that might bottled water it
would draw in the question the
Manchester waterwork large withdrawal
permit they have a well that goes
underneath the marac river and hooks it
and that has to be renewed every 10
years so we're not sure how this would
interplay with uh that type of H
you Gary Abbott associated general
contractors
thank you chairman again for the record
my name is Gary Abbott I'm the Executive
Vice President of the associated general
contractors of New Hampshire I will be
brief since Brandon kind of took my
thunder away representing contractors we
looked at this bill the original look
was we're not a bottled water company
but it says the department shall not
approve any large groundwater extraction
for bulk water so in the construction we
do an awful lot of water tank trucks for
dust control to meet the dust control
that Dees requires that we keep the dust
down for health and other reasons and so
there start to become a lot of questions
and it doesn't take too many water
trucks to equal
57,600 gallons so we were wondering if
this exclusion was going to impact the
construction industry and I know I
raised it with Brandon at our last
week's hearing and said this bill does
this affect me or not and it could
because I think there's real no
definition of bulk water and clearly we
consume some water in the construction
industry I would leave you with that so
that's why I'm here today to oppose it
uh I think our system that is already in
place is a good system with the
Department approving uh you know large
groundwater withdrawals in the process
they go through so I haven't heard
anybody testify that we have a problem
with our existing system and uh would
hope that you would uh not pass this
legislation thank you very much and
answer any questions any questions by
members of the of the
committee thank you seeing none thank
you very much uh Brian was you
Terry you mind if I speak with him I
have the other pin
Cardy together okay you
great
parasol thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee for the record my name is
Tom praw from deur and prol I'm here
today representing uh the international
bottled water Association which is a
trade Association representing all
segments of the bottled of water
industry with me is Brian guz from
Crystal Geyser Springs which is the
aformentioned one bottler that Mr Kieran
mentioned and uh they're located in
molten Boro and I thought uh for the
committee's uh interest it might be
helpful for Brian to speak a little bit
about his uh his company and what they
do here in the state as they've been
operating for over 20 years without any
issues uh good morning everybody uh it's
my first time doing something like this
so bear with me here um yeah Crystal
Geyser has been with with uh with mol
the molten Boro facility for over 20
years now um it's a family business we
started in the 90s in Southern
California um we've had the multim
facility since yeah
2002 2002 so a little bit over 20 years
and like previously stated um you know
the Regulatory Compliance is it's it's
already there it's already there we're
following the rules we're doing our part
we're heavily regulated we're sending
reports in every month um we've always
been in full compliance with state
regulations um consistently followed all
the
rules um for our bottling operations as
well um our pumping practices are
sustainable and um again all the
permitting processes are in place um to
ensure minimal impact on the
environment and also to demonstrate our
commitment to to regulat compliance it's
very important very important to us
um you know we're not just some big
greedy company we're heavily involved in
in the community um molten Boro um all
the local fire departments we're
constantly giving s uh donations out um
it's very important soccer soccer games
baseball games Cub Scouts uh we're
involved with those guys giving samples
out and uh hydrating people the best we
can
um food pantries as well um wanted to
talk about some of the financial
contributions to the community and the
state as well
[Music]
um yeah stimulating the economy U
$27,000 in property taxes to Molen Boro
in 2023 that's that's huge and then
280,000 in uh state taxes to New
Hampshire um we are stimulating the
economy here you know that's that's
doing our part we have many local
vendors that we're dealing with as well
many local vendors um local Pallet
Company um uh the film WP that we're
using is uh is local as well so lots of
local vendors um I wanted to touch on
employee commitment
also um we're providing we got about 20
full-time jobs uh there for folks
um it's full it's full um year round
employment for a lot of people um in
manufacturing world it's it's not always
easy you know you get uh a lot of
layoffs during slower Seasons we we
don't do that we keep everybody on year
round uh we're offering full
benefits zero out of pocket costs um to
everybody that's that's huge uh
especially
nowadays um prioritizing the the
well-being and security of our employees
and their
families um when CG rockan took over
in the early
2000s there we the company chose to keep
all the existing employees on board and
and that was huge it didn't can
everybody and start fresh like a lot of
other people do we kept everybody on um
kept them working and um it's kind of
interesting to this day we still have a
couple veterans with us so um yeah I
just I think that says a lot about the
company and who we are and you know our
employees working for us so it's
um it's uh it's what we do um that's
about all I've got I just wanted to kind
of say who we who we are and and uh talk
about what we're doing a little
bit and and uh as was stated you know in
addition to being a good corporate
citizen you know the international bed
Water Association has consistently
worked with the Department over the
years um and has supported uh the
permitting system uh and so you know we
haven't having not seen any issues we
don't see a need for this legislation
and would ask that you find it
inexpedient to
legislate happy to take any
questions
representative how many uh gallons per
day are you withdrawing I didn't hear
that I we regulated to that we do not go
over it I would have to get exact
numbers I don't have that in front of me
so that's under the
57,600 but how close Okay at some point
maybe you can send us an email I
absolutely will what you
withdraw thank you any other questions
by members of the
committee representative Derby thank you
Mr chair one of the um thank you very
much for taking my question yes yes um
one of the concerns we heard was about
plastic pollution plastic pollution is
very important to me as well so can you
talk about what you know your company
and the Bott water industry in general
is doing to address pathoplastic
pollution and you know look for
alternatives to avoid you know filling
our landfills that are you know under
strain in New Hampshire you've probably
seen those
bills thank you yeah I I do think this
is a separate topic but you know what
I'd be happy to touch on what we're
doing as a company um and I'm pretty
proud of this actually we we've made a
massive initiative here um we're proud
to say that every every bottle that we
produce is made with 50% postc consumer
plastic and we're doing that in our own
facilities we have one in Southern
California and one in Tennessee that the
owner is built um from the ground up
we're we're formulating our own clean
plastic and rep putting that into every
bottle that we're producing today it's a
massive foot forward for this pollution
problem it's 50% and we're on our way to
100% to close close the loop
completely you're
welcome and answer representative Wolf's
uh question my my good friend from the
Department handed me a piece of paper
that indicates they currently use
200,000 representative rung question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question I'm um so delighted
to hear about the recycling plants and
um would you ever consider constructing
one in New
Hampshire you know that's uh I'd have to
talk to the owner of about yeah why not
not you know why not it's a great
initiative it's a great initiative and I
think we're well like I said we're well
on the way to closing I think we're
moving outside are we not moving outside
of the B of the base of this well I just
but any other uh questions by members of
the
committee seeing none thank you very
much thank you thank you let's see
I think that's anyone else wish to speak
on
this if
not I'll close the hearing on House Bill
1277 establishing a committee to study
alternatives for funding the operation
maintenance and repair of state-owned
dams chair recognizes
representative
Harrington is
yours thank you Mr chairman and welcome
committee members um this um this bill
would I know do one of the things that
people don't even want to hear it
establish a study committee but in this
case I think it has some merits and I
hope you'll listen because as you've
probably seen um or heard U on the news
um there's a lot of problems with dams
in New Hampshire and it's getting
getting worse we've had uh a number of
dams and um the gentlemen from Dees will
go into more specifics on this but the
number of dams that have been considered
uh you know really a problem if they
would have fail has gone up drastically
not because we're making new dams but
because we're building stuff near dams
uh there was a a lot of uh publicity
last summer to a dam over from gtown
that would have uh I'm not sure what the
status of is right now but it was
planning to be torn down which would
have torn a lot of people's waterr
property from Waterfront into mudf front
um I know just in my my uh District on
the merry meeting River there's two or
three dams that are uh having problems
with them and you know a lot of this
goes back to uh federal regulations and
what's happened in the uh electric power
markets there was a time back in the
late 9 in the 90s actually where there
was a problem a program called qf of
qualified facilities and that meant if
you qualify as a renewable electric
generator you were getting paid based on
what people thought the rates were going
to be into the future which meant
sometimes the rates were as much as
three times the uh wholesale price of
electricity you were getting paid and
this spurred a lot of people into
putting hydroelectric facilities on some
of these dams some of them which were
there some of them which they
refurbished some they built new and over
time those contracts got so expensive
that uh Public Service AKA eversource
bought them out and others just expired
with time because there was a it was a
limited amount of time so now you have a
situation where they're not getting paid
anywhere near as much and a lot of those
people just simply abandon their license
and to look at renewing that is very can
be very expensive uh there's uh Federal
requirements on permitting and there's
also uh requirements on putting in fish
ladders whether or not there's fish
there to go up the ladder doesn't seem
to be an issue you have to build a fish
ladder if you want to relicense so
there's it's it's a major problem across
New Hampshire and like I say I'll have
the gentleman from Dees Cory do most of
the he'll give you the specifics on this
but the reason we want to set it up is I
was requested to put in the bill by Dees
and as written this is sort of a almost
a photocopy of a bill that was done
20-some years ago and I regret to say uh
almost that I was on that committee too
we had come up with some actions and uh
the problem's back again and it's gotten
worse um as written I wouldn't recommend
a couple of Chang es to the bill and
I've submitted this in writing on the uh
on the um web page the first one would
be to to go from three to one members of
the Senate because as you know if we got
one member of the Senate to show up
we're going to get lucky so no offense
to Senators but that's just the way the
world works the second one would be to
add a member from Dees appointed by the
dees uh commissioner like I said I
submitted this in writing to their
website because I think it's really
important to have their technical
expertise as a member of the committee
as well
and the other thing then and I this is
when really want to get a feel when you
you people hear more uh on this and you
obviously this is your field of
expertise but does it need to be
expanded to cover not just state owned
but Municipal owned uh dams as well
because I know a lot of town-owned
facilities are having problems I mean I
know of two in the towns I represent and
there's many more of them and I know
there's I think there's another bill uh
out somewhere that would allow the town
to buy a Dam from the state before the
before the state tore it down so maybe
these things can be worked uh together a
little bit but uh and I'll take any
questions but I think the experts the
me got any questions by members of the
committee
no representative Derby and Then
followed by representative R thank you
Mr chair um thank you representative
paron for taking my question I think you
said that you were on the commission
before 20 years ago or something that
studied a similar issue can you just
describe some of the solutions that were
um advocated at from that commission
actually I tried to find a copy of the
report last week without any luck I know
there were some uh but also the the
the the world has changed substantially
since then because of the law the you
know loss of those qualified facility
hydro plants and there's so much more uh
develop velopment around the dams uh
with it wasn't there before and and the
big difference is it it changes I mean
there's a couple of dams like that there
one over Northwood Meadow state parks
that sort of the whole lake went down by
itself because part of the dam failed
and then that clog that it went back up
again so it was really concerned is the
dam been damaged or not and so forth the
state's Park systems been over there
looking at but that's a low impact Dam
because there's nothing for Miles
Downstream of that that all you do is
flood a bunch of Meadows and so forth on
the other hand there's a there's a dam
in straford now that the school district
owns because they bought some land and
that's been upgraded to a substantial
impact because if it broke it could take
out a road uh you know a state highway
so I I don't remember that I would I
would try to get a copy and submit it to
the committee obviously but I don't have
it on my hands right
now Senator
Bron thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Harrington for taking my
question you mentioned in your testimony
that um this bill came about about from
work you had done or advice you'd gotten
from Dees is that correct um correct are
you aware of their current letter
regarding this bill where they recommend
it be amended to be more consistent with
um Senate Bill uh 549 and their
Amendment 0567 s yeah that's that's what
the gentl from Dees will speak of yeah
oh okay so I I just want to know but
you're in favor of that okay thank as
well as the ones I mentioned here
because I like I said you know let's be
realistic we're not going to get through
Senators to show up for a study
committee yeah that's true and I I would
want someone from Dees on the committee
you representative har thank you Mr
chair and thank you representative
Harrington for taking my
question if I just quickly read the
Senate bill and the Senate Amendment and
it very similar to your bill so why do
we need your bill well I guess I
submitted the bill quite some time ago
at the request Dees if you feel that
that bill coming this Direction covers
it adequately I have no problem with uh
withdrawing this bill and then you you
people will see it when it comes out of
the Senate I mean there's no need for
duplicate bills so if if just if I'm not
sure Mr chairman if I need to do
something on that but if the committee
requests that to be done and I have to
do it just give me a call and I'll do it
because I really don't want I mean uh I
don't think you guys like being here
every day any more than I do so um if
you're going to have one bill that's
going to do it let's let's have one bill
there's no need for two thank you for
answering my
question representative thank you Mr
chairman and I appreciate your
suggestion very much how do we go about
seeing whether the Senate Bill covers
everything in representative herance
bill or vice versa uh do we want to come
comes to exec do we it what I guess any
representative Mr chairman what is aure
to take care of that well we could we
can uh hold on to the bill until uh
until it we get Senate if it comes over
before crossover ends otherwise we'll
have to
just either take uh either pass it not
pass it or
I you know interim study those are are
three
options can't retain it because it's be
otherwise
be should that would have been that
would have been last year so we have we
have three options we are if I'm not
mistaken i' have to check but I think
believe we are taking up all of the
taking up all of these bills that we're
doing today next week
week try Mr chairman if I can I will try
to get in touch with the Senate and see
what the status is on that and get back
to you if that helps that that might
help anyone
you
good morning chairman members of the
committee I'm Corey clarf chief engineer
at the dam Bureau at the New Hampshire
Department of Environmental
Services and as we you were just
discussing um Dees does support this
bill if we incorporate some of those
changes that we've worked on in the
Senate version and I'll get into some of
those um here in a minute so as as
you've heard
um the nhds Dam Bureau is responsible
for all uh state owned dams in New
Hampshire roughly in New Hampshire we
have about 273 state-owned dams uh about
100 of those are owned by nhdes another
100 owned by fishing game and the
remainder are owned by do UNH veterans
home and a couple other
agencies Dees is responsible for the
operation and maintenance of all of
those Dees and fishing game owned dams
roughly 208 dams and so the average age
of these Dam dams is around 100 years
and a lot of these dams have not seen
rehabilitation in 40 to 50 years or even
longer time periods and so we're really
coming into a time in which we're we're
looking at our capital investment that's
needed to keep this inventory up and as
just a quick study that we did earlier
this year we we analyzed all the
different dams those 273 dams and came
up with a figure of roughly $414 million
to repair all state-owned dams and out
of that 414 million roughly 300 million
is needed just for the repair of
high-hazard dams in New Hampshire or
high Hazard state owned dams there are
63 of those one thing um to note is when
when this issue was looked at in 2004 as
the representa Harrington mentioned
there were 20 29 High Hazard dams at
that time now obviously the state of New
Hampshire has not built another 34 dams
since that time the issue has really
come down to two things one there's
increased devel Downstream of dams when
development occurs um the the the dam
can be reclassified to a high Hazard if
the failure of that dam was to impact
one of those structures Downstream just
real quick on the hazard classifications
when I mention High Hazard it's you
could have a brand new dam that still
meets that criteria has nothing to do
with the condition of the dam it's
solely based upon if that dam was to
fail whether it's new whether it's old
and impacts uh residents or businesses
Downstream in which possible loss of
life could occur that is a high Hazard
Dam so we have state of in Hampshire
owns 63 of those currently and as I
mentioned roughly to bring all those
High Hazard dams into current criteria
we'd be looking at about 300 million
dollar of capital
investment
so how do we how do we currently pay for
all all of this well currently we we use
the dam maintenance fund and capital
funds and general funds to cover the
majority of all of these expenses the
dam maintenance fund was created in 1989
and the the sole outside Revenue that
comes into that fund is from Hydro
leases the state of New Hampshire leases
nine sites to Hydro power developers
those sites such as Lakeport Dam on the
Outlook outload of
winaki uh ponok Dam up in uh Miland on
the Andre Skagen um we have dams over on
the PCAT quog as
well and so the the rent payments that
are based on the revenue coming into
those hydropower facilities go into the
dam maintenance fund
however over time the revenue has
significantly dropped during the first
13 years of the D maintenance fund that
fund was primarily um covering all
expenses at the dam Bureau and the
reason for that is because not only with
the expenses less at that point in time
but also these hydropower developers
were in power purchase agreements with
PS H at that time and so they were
getting anywhere from 8 cents to 70
cents a kilowatt hour for the the power
they were producing in in 2002 PSNH re
renegotiated their um Power purchase
agreements as as part of the RSA 374
which was the electric utility
restructuring legislation that came
through at that time so since then since
2003 the hydrop power developers have
been getting current market rates for
their power which last year averaged
about 3.6 cents a kilowatt hour so not
only are the revenues going down for the
hydropower producers but at the same
time the regulatory requirements are
going up uh a lot of these sites are
seeing relicensing that is taking place
this is a license that is generated
through the Federal Energy Regulatory
Commission those licenses typically are
good for 40 years and a lot of these
sites were developed in the 1980s 1970s
so a lot of those sites are now up for
relicensing and not only the
requirements to relicense a site but
also the future requirements as part of
that license are really uh driving some
of
the financial issues that we have at
these hydropower sites along with
obviously the declining uh return on uh
the
declining rate for power that the these
sites are seeing and so with all that um
with all that being said the dam Bureau
has continued to rely more and more on
Capital funds and general funds in order
to meet our goals and obligations for
the operation of the 208 dams and also
the repair and reconstruction of the 273
dams and so with this committee we can
look at is is it time to re-evaluate how
the dam maintenance fund is funded
should we continue looking at hydrop
power or can we look at other other
sources and as I previously mentioned
in 2004 a similar committee was formed
under s SP 488 to review the effects of
this electrical utility
restructuring some of the outcomes that
came out of that and this is the report
that was previously mentioned was um to
look at uh the unfunded roll toll or gas
tax to boers short front maintenance
fees increased fishing license fees
increased boat registration fees
increased Ming permit fees increasing
par fees and leasing additional
dams however after after subsequent
legislative efforts in the years after
that uh committee developed their report
uh none of those we all the other all
the recommendations I previously
mentioned with the exception of the
first two
actually were found to be deficient and
not recommended to the committee for
further analysis those first two I
mentioned the unfunded roll toll gas to
boers in the shorefront maintenance fee
failed to make it out of the legislature
at that time so we we continued to use
the dam maintenance fund since that time
however we've been continuing to rely
more and more on Capital and general
fund to to meet our needs and
obligations I will add though however
we've been fortunate that there have
been uh Federal money that we've been
able to tap in tap into to help cover
some of our expenses but uh currently
we're still seeing those uh capital and
general fund expenses continue to
Cline so the other two pieces of this
legislation that I just want to mention
uh that tie into the the uh the bill
currently going through the Senate s SP
549 would be one to clarify that the
revenue resulting from the sale or
transfer to dams as well as other
Revenue can be deposited in the dam
maintenance fund currently the way the
statute is written the dam maintenance
fund receives funding from the leasing
of these
sites one way that we're trying to
diminish our revenue is we're actually
looking at um selling some of these
sites so we have a hydrop power site
that's currently going to be going
through relicensing uh the hydr power
developer that leases that site is
actually looking to purchase that site
at the open market rate and so we are
looking to actually sell that site so we
want to make sure that the revenue that
comes in from the that sale is able to
go into this Dam maintenance fund for
the repair and reconstruction of
state-owned dams the other legislation
would be to amend RSA 42 Goen
12 to clarify when it's appropriate for
nhds to reclassify Mena
stams several years ago uh 42 col2 was
created or amended rather so that
essentially we had these grandfather
non- Mena stams and here in New
Hampshire we have uh four different
Hazard classifications we have the high
Hazard that I already spoke about we
have significant Hazard low Hazard and
non- menace non- menace dams are
essentially these dams that are in the
middle of nowhere usually privately
owned but sometimes publicly owned um in
which if they were to fail no one would
other than the landowner there's no
threat Downstream or anything like that
however one thing we found is that some
of these dams do pose a threat to
Downstream infrastructure and we just
want to clarify the language in the
current statute so that if that non-
Menace Dam cannot discharge the required
amount of water to ensure that the
downstream area is being protected then
uh we would we would go in and
reclassify that Dam to make sure it can
discharge one one example of this is uh
this this summer up in Newport there was
a non- Mena Stam in which we looked at
in
2019 because of the because of the
statute we could not reclassify it
however we did at that time observe a
downstream driveway and a structure that
could have been impacted sure enough in
July the stam actually failed and took
out that Downstream driveway and so
we're just looking to clarify this so
that way moving forward we hopefully
don't run into these similar issues and
so with that um that's all I have today
and I'll open up for questions
I have a
question uh Senate Bill
549 is that similar to what's being
asked in this bill or is that you list
made a list of uh of actual action items
is that in Senate Bill 549 are those
action items occurring yes yes Senate
Bill 549 already includes those two
other action items okay so Senate Bill
549 is actually jumped ahead of what
this bill is actually doing what
actually
proposing uh if this is this is a
proposing of committee to discover stuff
to do Senate Bill 549 is actually doing
stuff right proposing it Senate Bill 549
is is is very the only difference
between that bill and and this bill is
that it includes those other two um
other two requests to amend the existing
statutes okay so it already has so it's
actually has has this but it also has
other other goodies
yes any other questions Representative
no Rong yeah Mr chair I did check up and
just for you um the information the
question you brought up before um Senate
Bill 549 has been approved by the senate
committee it's on the consent calendar
for their session
tomorrow good as
amended maybe if they release it they'll
might even get it before crossover uh
any other questions by
uh members of the committee
representative Darby thank you thank you
Mr chair representa Point uh thank you
for taking my question just to confirm
so the department um supports um 549 as
amended Senate 549 as amended okay thank
you
y representative ho for a question
does your uh Authority go to Bieber dams
no no these are just just solely
man-made structures and the current
definition of a dam and statue is any
structure over six feet in height
there's a couple other nuances but
overall it's any man-made structure over
six feet in height that's impounding
water thank
you representative Lon question thank
you Mr chair and thanks for taking my
question which may be um not really
Germain but are there any other
classifications besides a menace
structures that Dees applies to whether
a dam should be rebuilt or not such as
populations So currently the way the
reclassification process works is a dam
is is reviewed by by the dam safety
inspector or internally at Dees and
really it's a it's a review of potential
Downstream impacts that affect life
property and economic losses and also in
those economic losses you can look at
town roads state roads that sort of
thing but purely from an ecological
standpoint they are not
reclassified if if that answers your
question they're not okay
thank any other questions by members of
the
committee one additional thing this is
only state owned dams we're not talking
about Municipal and not talking about
private uh over the years it's been a
big deal around privately owned dams uh
people wanting to be turned over to the
state and the state saying no we can't
afford it yeah when we mentioned the dam
maintenance fund that fund is only used
for the repair reconstruction or
operation of state-owned
dams any other questions representative
Derby thank you Mr chair um thank you
again for taking my question um
representative Herrington actually sort
of asked the question I'm
just um just want to follow up on what
representative Rulo just asked which is
that um I understand that what the
maintenance fund is used for as you just
described but should the um uh
should the commission study um Municipal
well it is certainly a an issue for
municipal dams and privately owned dams
how do you how do you fund these things
you know you you have of course at here
at the State of New Hampshire we have
our own funding resources that we can
put into these um however there are
plenty of dams that are owned out there
by municipalities and there are plenty
of dams that are owned out there by
either Lake Associations or Village
districts
I can tell you that all of them are
struggling of trying to figure out how
do we go and fund these these projects
obviously when it comes to a municipal
owned Dam um there are municipal owned
dams that are leased out to hydrop power
I believe the city of NASA has a couple
of those um so but obviously the way
they handle things is completely
different than how none of none of
um none of the rules or regulations or
statutes that I'm aware of that apply to
how Dees leases out our properties to
hydrop power producers apply to any
Municipal owned dams or anything of that
nature and then um to further answer
your question uh the the dams that are
owned by either Village districts or
municipalities that don't have a
hydropower entity they are then looking
at either the residents of the community
or in the village District or they're
looking at the residents around that
that body of water to to come up with
the funds necessary to do the repairs
and operations and it is always a
challenge
so for a followup thank you Mr chair um
thank you again so it sounds like the
what you're the recommendation here for
this um for this commission is to look
at the um the the damn whatever the the
state Dam fund and you know how that
gets funded for state owned dams and
maybe there's a problem with
municipalities and privately owned dams
but you know the stud's got to be sort
of constrained that's what you're saying
yeah I I believe so just just because of
the way that funding can be raised to to
do this you know the way municipalities
can you know with their property taxes
and everything else and the way they can
raise money is different than how we can
these any other questions by members of
the
committee is that
Point uh do I understand this correctly
most of the money that comes in for your
operations in the various
funds uh their Cash Cow is uh
hydroelectric production correct thank
you I I will just build upon that we we
do also have um seven other accounts
that solely are for what we call Project
accounts and those are funded through
water user agreements which are also
tied to hydrop power so for just for an
example there is a uh water user
agreement for what we call the wiip
pasak project money that goes into that
account is solely to be used for the
sites that the state owns within the
wnab basaki river Lochmere Dam Lakeport
Dam that the money gets into that fund
by us essentially releasing the water
for Downstream hydropower users so those
hydrop power users along the winaki
river and then the hydrop power users
even down within the marac uh amsk
Garbin Falls uh hooks it they pay into
this water user fund but once again
those funds can only be used and even
and even only can be used for those
particular projects and even in that
case we're looking at Capital needs that
exceed the amount of money that are in
funds representative uh um well do you
have Surplus in any of those I think you
said seven designated
funds very minor Surplus just to make
sure that we're not going over in into
our not exceeding what's in that Surplus
but we we try to keep a a positive
balance from year to year on
those thank
you seeing no additional
questions thank you very much thank you
the last card and I'll close the hearing
1277 and
that's coming back now at 1
o' so you have a long
lunch huh I got my
minority
you
e
open the hearing on HB
1314 FN and recognize the prime sponsor
representative Grassi welcome back it's
great to be back Mr chairman and uh for
the record my name is representative
Chuck grassy I representative Rochester
W 4 and uh I'm here to introduce HB 1314
and before I start with the discussion
of the bill I'd like to read something
that was written by someone who worked
on this with me uh um and basically what
she wrote was when when the slogan the
New Hampshire Advantage was first coined
it was linked to our income and sales
tax policies our tax policies were
important but just as important the
Priceless intangibles New Hampshire
offers it's incomparable natural beauty
its healthy environment the intent of
this bill is to remember that we are the
stewards of our lands and Waters and
must balance development and growth and
the products of modern society with
responsibilities to use protect and
treasure our water systems our landscape
if we do not identify and counteract
threats both natural and man-made if we
do not protect the inheritance of our
children the New Hampshire are Advantage
will become nothing more than an empty
and ironic
slogan Mr chairman uh when I was growing
up a kid I always remember on our
license police you say Scenic New
Hampshire people came to New Hampshire
historically for its beauty they came
here for the environment for clean water
for the clean for clean air and when we
looked at the new at the state
development plan
um what we found is is that nobody was
looking at the environment as part of
our um as as something we should protect
as a resource here in the state um the
state development plan was basically
written back in 2000 and by order of
this legislature and they said in the
statutes that it should be updated every
four years in 2003 they were supposed to
start and they did but nothing ever
happened became of that when I called
legislative services and said could you
get me a copy of the state comprehensive
development plan they said we can't find
it they called me back in 3 days and
they said we can't find the plan at
State Library doesn't even have a copy
of the plan now this is from
2000 and I happen to know a planner
friend of mine who works for the state
and I said did you check in with this
person they called him and he said I
happen to have one in a box in the
bottom of my closet in my office and so
now the state has a copy of the state
development plan but it goes through and
it talks about a number of sections if
you take a look at at section n A and B
of the uh of the rsas it talks about uh
what we need to protect and how we need
to manage our resources in the state but
it does nothing as far as the
environment is concerned so what I did
is I drafted up a section and working
with some other folks up in the Lakes
region in particularly uh we drafted out
a section and we try to include
everything that we looked at as as that
we should be protecting in the state of
New Hampshire as as as far as our
environmental concerns our Waters our
Lakes our air quality and then we also
drafted a section of the development
plan dealing with um with threats so
that hopefully if this development plan
is updated every four years as the RSA
say it should be what uh what we'd be
looking at is that every four years the
state would take on the job of going
over what are our what do we have for
resources as far as the environment is
concerned and what are the threats so
every four years it wouldn't be
something that we would be reacting to
threats to our environment such as Pas
but we something that every four years
we would be looking for what what
threats should we be
anticipating in the state of New
Hampshire now people have said well this
is going to cost a ton of money I'm not
looking for any money here and and I
really I'm not asking you to do much at
all what I'm asking you to do is put
this in the state development plan if
the legislature determines the wisdom
next year in a budget year that they
don't want to fund it then basically
nothing will be done but it will be in
the
plan so that if a future legislature
decides to fund it next year I'll be
coming in in a budget year asking that
we fund this plan so that we go through
and we take a look at all of the factors
that are important for for the
development of the State of New
Hampshire both economic and
environmentally that we when we do take
a look at those things um we we we look
at the environment because right now if
we updated the environmental resources
plan we would not be looking at any
environmental resources whatsoever but
by adding this section and adding a
section on threats it would make that
happen and I'll be happy to answer any
questions we have any questions for the
Lon thank you for taking my question um
what state agency is responsible for
producing the plan well it would be
headed up by the um office Planning and
Development whatever it's called
nowadays because it's changed its names
a number of times they would basically
head it up and they would work with the
particular agencies that would be
responsible for that if it was something
that dealing with environmental issues
I'm sure they would be taught working
with the folks at d yes um if it was to
deal with Industrial Development and
resources as far as land use for
industrial another section of the the
plan which currently exist they would
look for the the the business and
industry Association they would probably
work with them to help them develop a
plan uh so you they would be able to
pull everything together and in the
document it talks about that the office
of Planning Development has
responsibility for for doing this thank
you any other questions for the
representative
celly
thank you be for being here
representative so um just reading
through your proposal the the state has
a a 10-year Forest plan that the
division of uh Boris and L puts out
every year very comprehensive plan so in
this type of thing they would you're
you're saying that the office would just
reach out to them and then take those
pieces and plug it right in yeah plans
there are a lot of individual plans up
here this is a place where the
legislature back in 2000 tried to
centralize everything and so what they
would do is if there are plans like that
they would just pull those into this
here so and and be able to update it
more frequently and that's what we're
hoping to
do representative run thank you Mr chair
and thank you representative grassy for
taking my question how do you see this
plan um interfacing with local
municipalities uh one example I'm
thinking of is perhaps in protection of
a New Hampshire Waterway um the this
plan might call for expansion of a
sewage system that might take over you
know across many Town boundaries um how
would this plan help coordinate with
those different
towns well I think that what you'd be
looking at here in this plan if it was
to develop something which wanted to
protect a certain Waterway and there was
the advantage to regionalizing uh
septics in and we do have some Regional
septic facil Wastewater facilities here
in the state of New Hampshire uh
Franklin being one of one of them is
that it would give more State impetus to
those plans that if we looked at that we
need to do more work more regionally and
as we know waste water um air quality um
contaminants do not recognize Town
boundaries uh communities have their
Master plans the state has its master
plan 2000 was the last time we did a
master plan for the State of New
Hampshire and I'm looking at that if we
update the plan we just have a section
that recognizes that the environment is
a resource um you know it's it's always
been a resource for us and we seem to be
looking away from that thank
you any other questions for the
representative I I have one can you
comment on the fiscal note although you
say you're not asking for money the
business and economic Affairs state that
this may require a third party vendor to
help draft the plan with the uh planning
and development office and could could
cost money for the next year but still
it costs money if we put it in the plan
it it certainly would would cost some
money at some point in time whether it
be a third party vendor that they hire
to bring in to do this plan or if it's a
commission that we have internally uh
the state can report ad when this was
originally written it was written with
the office of planning and development
and uh a commission of individuals that
represented uh business interest and
ended up uh you know and and represented
other interests in the state of New
Hampshire uh resour that represented
resources they didn't take into
account the environment and that's what
I think they you know it was the
environment was a secondary thought to
everything else they were doing we
should have a section that talks about
the environment itself so yeah it will
cost money to put this plan together and
and over this year so I saying I'm not
looking us for doing it this year just
get it into the plan and then next year
I will come in with a budget proposal to
actually Implement to do update to the
plan thank you no other questions for
the representative don't seeing none
thank you for your test thank
you our next and last pink card Andrea
favor right good afternoon I'm Andrea
Laro uh president of New Hampshire lakes
and it's nice to see you all and uh we
are here in support of this bill and I'd
like to Echo um all that representative
grassy said uh this seems like common
sense when we're um coming up with a a
plan a development plan for the state
that we include the environment and we
include a look forward to threats to our
environment we know and I know this
committee knows lakes and ponds in
particular are so important to the state
of New Hampshire for so so many reasons
unfortunately uh you all also know that
our lakes and ponds are experiencing
some really serious
degradation
and I would like to think that if we had
the environment and a look forward to
the risks to the environment in a state
a planning process in a planning process
that actually um you know continued um I
know it's been since 2000 since I've
done this document but to every uh four
or five years look at the environment
how we're developing it um and the
threats that we might not be in such a
reactive mode I feel like we are in a
very reactive mode to what is happening
to the health of our Lakes right now and
I know this committee has heard a lot
about uh toxic
cyanobacteria um and that's you know a
really serious problem that I feel like
we're behind the eightball here in New
Hampshire and it would have been nice to
to be able to be in a position you know
four or five years ago to sort of um
take some precautions to to help
minimize um this issue that we're
dealing with and I shutter to think what
other risks might be out there um for
our lakes that we don't even know about
so I'm hopeful that inclusion of the
environment and threats into a planning
process that does actually happen every
four or five years will help us better
Steward our Lakes uh for cleaner and
healthier lakes that again are so so
important to our state for so many
reasons so I thank you for this
opportunity to comment and I'd be happy
to answer any questions any questions
for our
speaker
singan thank you for your testimony
thanks so much have a good afternoon
thank you is there anyone else to speak
1314 I'll ask again anyone else to speak
on HB 1314 seeing no one approaching the
mic close the hearing on hb1 1314 FN our
next hearing is at 2 pm hb1 1440 FN
thank
you
e
I'll open the hearing on hb1
144 FN and ask the prime sponsor
representative uh
gallager hi I'm representative Eric
Gallagher representing Marat County
District 20 which is conquered War 6 and
I'm here to
introduce um House Bill
1440 uh relative to establishing a life
jacket luner station program along the
marac river so yeah as I mentioned I'm
from conquer which is one of the many um
communities along the mar ma River in
New Hampshire um and
one um one problem that has caught my
eye in the community has been um people
who have drowned in the marac rever um
so yeah it's something um f first one I
can remember um going back to 2013 um 11
years ago um already there um there was
this guy in my neighborhood we knew um
who went by Krabby who um ran into us
one fourth of July we were like and we
knew he always like to go swimming at
the river up at SWS Falls so um we ran
to him 1/4th of July and um just talking
about how high the river had gone up
lately and he's like oh yeah I've been
up there watching to make sure people
don't drown and um then at turns out in
the news the next few days later we find
out that he himself had drowned so um I
mean yeah people do know that it's
dangerous um but um sometimes the
resources just aren't there um so there
was also um so um there was also some
reporting in the Boston Globe um last
year 2022 um about how there have been
um 31 people have died in the river over
the last 12 years um it mentioned some
um it mentioned some people who have
been doing some advocacy um to try to
reduce drings in it um so yeah that made
me think of how we could actually um
address this from a policy point of view
so um that summer uh I actually went and
did a survey of the public access sites
along the river um basically the places
where you can put in your boat or
whatever um to see what sort of uh
safety features they had um and I took a
bunch of pictures um not not really sure
what the best way to share them with you
all is but um if any of you wants to see
them um just let me know um so yeah one
of the things I found when doing the
survey of um Public Access along the mar
ma rever
um well all right I'll I'll I'll go in
order um one of them some one of them
even had a little Memorial to someone
who had drowned there at it like that
people had just made up on their own
initiative um there were a bunch of
signs none of them said specifically
much of anything um about being careful
while swimming though they're mostly um
the most of the signs were um about like
making sure that you don't have invasive
um plants stuck here canoe paddles and
stuff um
so yeah um eventually though at one of
the putins um I did find something kind
of relevant to what I was looking for at
the um
nhti boat ramp I discovered that there
was a life jacket loner station there um
and um yeah
basically just a sign um and a board
with a bunch of life jackets on it that
um people
could uh that people could borrow when
going swimming there to um you know used
to keep themselves safe um so I thought
oh hey that's a good idea let's um see
how
um let's see how we can get more of
these distributed um along the river um
so I was going to think on it a little
while um give it a little bit more
thought but then um this summer there
was another drowning and that just kind
of prompted me to um that just kind of
prompted me to hurry with it so I asked
OS what they could draft for me um for
um the creation of more of these life
jacket larer station so um this is the
bill they drafted for me um the current
ones
are
um mostly done
um yeah they're um the yeah the current
ones are are done by the US Coast Guard
um Safe Kids USA um so some federal
things and some local things but it's
not something that the state of New
Hampshire is participating in though so
um yeah I
think um yeah also the Children's
Hospital at Dartmouth the city of
conquered fire department some boy
scouts and nhci also all work together
on it so um I think
basically um the best thing to do here
would be for the State of New Hampshire
to help these existing organizations get
more of these um set up and basically be
involved as a partner with the existing
efforts and I hope that this bill um
will help make that happen and I'll take
questions now does anyone have a
question representative
Ron thank you Mr Speaker and thank thank
you representative Gallagher for taking
my question and I really want to commend
you for your compassion and empathy for
people that are at risk using the Marram
River um I have a question though is
there anything um that's pre that
prevents municipalities from already
doing this there may be Public Access
within their Town limits that might not
have a lot of activity or might have a
lot of activity is it something they
could take on on their own um I mean
yeah municipalities could
theoretically um do this themselves but
um and yeah this city of conquered fire
department was taking part in the nhti
one but I mean I'm not on my city
council I'm a state representative so
this is the Avenue that I have available
to me um I do think it's a Statewide
issue since the river flows through the
entire State um you know people will
often
uh go through multiple towns when um say
canoeing or
um or tubing or um boating or some other
sort of boating along the river um so I
I think it does make sense for the state
to be involved in um efforts like this
okay thank
you representative Dunn and then
representative white thank you Mr chair
why limit it just to the mayac why not
making more rivers in New Hampshire um
well the marac river is the one that
I've primarily heard the most about
drownings on um so yeah um biggest
rivers in New Hampshire um so yeah
there's also the Connecticut um but that
is partially shared with Vermont um and
at least from my experience with it is
um a lot calmer than the marac like the
marac has actual Rapids on it um you
know SW Falls even has a um a rating on
it a a white waterer rating class um so
um yeah um then just thinking about the
other big river systems um in New
Hampshire like the socco flows into main
pretty quickly before it gets big enough
to
um before it gets big enough to really
be dangerous and same thing with the
Andrew Scoggin so I think the marac is
um the Marx's kind of the most important
of them just due to the
um not its proximity to the centers of
population in the state and the um
number of people from the state that
it representative hoy
have you
considered uh p uh uh private
and public cooperation other words could
a um a water ski company by splattering
their stuff all over would they Supply
the the
equipment uh at no cost because I you
know this is a financial note so um I
mean so the wording is the division of
State Police Police Department of Safety
shall seek funding donations and
volunteer assistance in installing and
maintaining PFD
access um at Public Access sit so yeah I
mean I think the wording as it exists
does allow for um public private
Partnerships of that sort yeah
this follow yeah uh I'm working on that
so um I think this
is that's a good way to get this funded
without spending taxpayer money
so um and I think that would be
possible under the way the bills exist
existing any other questions
representative uh Derby thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
representative I'm trying to understand
are you I
suggesting that this that this bill um
ask the state to work with um
municipalities and other um private um
water owners that um or sorry land
owners that provide public access to the
water uh to the marac in particular um
to set up uh life Jack stations or is
this uh restricted to just state-owned
um Public Access well um I
mean
so
um well all right I'm just going to try
to think of the public access sites I
reviewed um but like they did already
all have some sort of State signage on
them already like um the stuff that's
required um by law about um like boting
regulations and whatever um yeah some of
them were near private property but um
you know I think the fact that they are
our Public Access sites um already shows
that the state already has sort of a
claim to them um you know another other
thing about the river is it's kind of
regarded as a public right of way um for
people to travel along um there's
actually um what another thing I found
besides the public access points was
there's uh the state requires Portage
trails around
the um hydroelectric dams on the uh
River and
um
so yeah there are some of those as well
um so I think that kind of shows another
way in which the
um the river can be seen as a public
resource that the state
on any other questions
I have one
representative um have you read the
fiscal note there were at least three
major bullet points in it that I thought
addressed your bill I don't think from
your testimony I heard you answer the
bullet points have you got an answer to
the bullet points in the fiscal note
like the first one was where are these
access points are they on private land
not private land um
the number of
stations I didn't know if you had an
opportunity to review it and might have
a response um so yeah the um Public
Access sites along the river that is
something that we actually do have
mapped um my my dad actually works for
the um office of plan development and
business and economic Affairs and that
was one of the things he worked on was
mapping the public access sites on all
bodies of water within New Hampshire um
but the um I
mean the um build doesn't
specify a specific number of them though
um so I mean I
think um
it's it's really basically up to how far
the department of safety wants to go
with this um and um I I think um
we can generally trust the department of
safety to um choose a number of sites to
put these at that is um both fiscally
responsible and um and beneficial to the
public
safety any other questions for the
representative seeing none thank you for
introducing the bill okay um and yeah I
have to actually
go back to HHS so thanks for having me
thank
you if I can read the handwriting uh
Easton Dartmouth health I could read
that
Jim how do you spell your last
name
Dion
when you turn it on you'll see the red
light thank
you uh good afternoon everyone for the
record my name is Jim eston I work for
the injury prevention center at
Dartmouth Health um and also coordinates
Safe Kids New Hampshire which is a part
of Safe Kids worldwide uh we're one of
the the coalitions that are there I have
to tell you we're we're really pleased
to see HB 1440 come before the committee
it's nice that we'll be able to have an
open dialogue about preventing drowning
in New Hampshire and drowning is the
fifth leading cause of death for
children in the state of New Hampshire
for unintentional
injury the CDC states that promising
drowning prevention strategies include
learning basic swimming and water safety
skills installing
barriers uh closely supervising children
at all times when in in when in or near
water and wearing life jackets at all
times when boating or among weaker
swimmers when swimming in natural water
settings in New Hampshire most of our
drownings occur in non-traditional
swimming areas um in other areas of Open
Water fatalities are just part of the
problem as NE drownings can be
devastating to a family as well the
darmouth health trauma program has seen
six um admissions in The Last 5 Years
which I know it doesn't sound like huge
huge number but when you think about the
brain injury that can result from lack
of oxygen over that time it it's a
significant amount of money that goes
through that I also reached out to
conquered Hospital they've had three in
the last five years and almost 20 in the
last since
2019 um this is admissions only and does
not capture emergency department data
nor do I have the EMS Ambulance run data
for the State of New Hampshire I was
working on that but didn't have enough
time to get that for you but when I do
I'll be happy to pass it along the
injury prevention center in Safe Kids
New Hampshire recommends properly worn
and used life jackets as an effective
barrier to drowning and near drowning
we've worked with our clinical and
non-clinical staff at Dartmouth Health
CH Dartmouth Health children's to
provide over 225 jackets to our most
vulnerable and atrisk pediatric patients
we have also partnered with 19
communities around the state to provide
signage and 190 life jackets for laner
stations I've attached a photo I I wish
I had been able to print it for you in
color but um this particular loner
station is at um at masoma Lake and
Enfield I know that the one you're
probably most familiar with actually has
a a big board with hooks for the life
jackets that that can be uh relatively
expensive but this is a pretty
costeffective way it's just a um bin
that they keep the life jackets in um
they also did the same thing the sunnye
police department does the same thing at
m at Lake snipe they have just a regular
tote that you would pick up at um
Walmart to provide for the um life
jacket
storage life jacket laner stations a
proven way of providing life-saving
equipment to those who need the most
children in and adults on or near water
they can be set up at Waterside
locations or made available through
local businesses fire stations police
departments or any number of agencies
they don't have to be anything special
they just need to be
accessible in closing I hope you will
consider the importance of this bill and
how we can work together to make this
type of life-saving measure and others
available to our citizens I appreciate
your time and um please ask any
questions that you might have that I can
answer for you thank you any questions
for the
speaker
yes thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh could you tell me
how many stations you're involved in in
terms of these uh uh loner stations we
we've provided life jackets to 19 laner
stations around the state um two of
which are on the marac river um what we
what we try to do when we seek out
communities is look for
organizations um and it it can be a
business it can be a uh the police
department someplace where there would
be access um to the life jackets at
least the majority of daylight hours and
what we're looking for the town know
where their issues are better than I do
and so we really rely on them to figure
out the best locations to set up those
stations follow up follow
up who maintain is there a certain
quantity that you leave at each station
and who maintains the sanitation for
these things so that would be the
sanitation would be up to the group that
takes on the life jackets we provide 10
life jackets per Community I will add
that um we're willing to work in have uh
or will have um enough like life jackets
200 for 20 communities in the state of
New Hampshire in 2024 and would love to
work with any uh communities that you
might identify on the mirac river or
not thank
you representative Darby thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
um what's the funding source that you
use for you know buying the life jackets
and the you know bins and so forth
thank you for the question uh the
funding that we have currently comes
from our Chad philan Children's Hospital
at Dartmouth philanthropy funds um so
it's in the past we've been able to get
donations from larger retailers to help
out with that that has kind of dried up
over the since Co actually um but we are
able to work with our fundraisers at
Dartmouth to provide this um and and
I'll I'll tell you how it all started
for us was um one pediatric case near
drowning um
and out of that case we developed a
program to provide not only CPR for the
parents but life jackets for kids
indeed follow up thank you Mr chair um
and what's the the what are the
maintenance costs um shrinkage for
example you know people maybe that don't
return them or that that are damage or
um you know cleaning cleanliness uh
types of things what can you comment on
that I can it depends on the location I
can tell you at the one here in conquer
um the first first year we actually
ended up with more than we lost um the
second year though we we lost a
significant number um and that was due
to to uh some of the folks along the
river that were taking them and selling
them um
so we we gave some um to conquered fire
department again a few uh two years ago
in 2022 so that they would have that um
you can count
on um not just with loss but with damage
and that kind of thing um losing at
least half of those you during the
course of the year you're
welcome any representative Ron thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question um of the drownings which ones
are you aware of where the person didn't
intend to go in the water or um maybe
they were close too close to shore let's
say with the river and fell in relative
to those who deliberately go in the
water to go swimming and they just lose
control or get injured mhm thank thank
you for the question um I'm I don't have
any individual cases I don't have that
information um I can tell you that um
many of our cases especially in the
Fring Seasons like spring and fall are
due to the cold water and without a life
jacket if they have a life jacket it'll
give them the time to get to shore
without it hypothermia starts to set in
and they're weak and and if they're not
a strong swimmer to begin with they'll
have the issue of not being able to make
it so follow up thank you so some of
these drownings people may not even
recognize that they would need a life
jacket because they're not expecting to
go in the water so do you see that as a
hindrance to getting use because people
just say well I'm not going to go in the
water I'm going to walk along the river
I'm going to walk on the ice not
thinking that they're going to end up in
the water so again a great question we
recommend that anyone that's out ice
fishing is with children um the children
have the life jacket on um especially if
they're using some type of vehicle to
get out on the ice um but you're right I
mean if nobody's expecting to go
swimming but they drop in in a case like
that it certainly wouldn't help them but
for the ones that do know they're going
in a boat or on the or near the water
it's a great
tool thank you any other questions I got
one yes representative Hoy thank
you st St
statistically how many of these
drownings also involved head
injury I don't have the statistic on
that I'm sorry um I'm hoping that my
colleague will be able to answer that
for you but I can tell you that um the
ones that I'm personally familiar with
um two out of the three had a head
injury um resulting from diving into a
log
followup
um is it something is it something
you're going to consider relative
to uh headgear safety as well like Cano
certainly canoas
kayakers probably could end up smashing
their head and drowning yeah um right
now you know our emphasis is on the life
jacket certainly you know any
consideration we can make to to protect
people um we're happy to
consider any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank
you our next speaker in support of the
DHHS
good
afternoon um my name is Rhonda seagull
and I am the uh head section head of the
maternal and child health section uh
within the division of Public Health
Services um at the New Hampshire
Department of Health and Human
Services um I've been there a long time
uh prior to me being the I was the
injury prevention um advisor and uh
program uh manager and uh Jim and I have
been colleagues for um a quarter
probably quarter of a century now right
um
uh I want to talk to you a little bit
about um some statistics and about um
our child fatality Review Committee that
is within U maternal and child health
the department is in support of hb1 1440
relative to establishing a life jacket
laner station program um along the marac
river so as Jim said drowning remains
one of the leading causes of preventable
death amongst uh children and young
people in New Hampshire um it's the
second leading cause of unintentional
injury death in children ages 1 through
18 years and the third leading cause of
unintentional injury death in those
under one years of age um between 2017
and
2021 there were approximately 150
emergency department visits at New
Hampshire
hospitals um due to near drownings
amongst Children and adolescents um uh
up to the age of 21 uh 17 of those of
the same age age and in the same period
were hospitalized and those are the more
serious um uh head injuries that uh uh
Jim was talking
about uh a good portion of the drowning
deaths and near drownings that required
emergency department visits and
hospitalizations in this state uh take
place in open bodies of water as opposed
to a bathub or um you know someone's
private pool um it's well known um as as
the representative at the beginning said
uh that the marac um River has been the
location of a disproportionate number of
um both fatalities and injuries um both
in Massachusetts and New Hampshire um I
didn't realize I was doing a little bit
more research on the marac it's like one
of the most dangerous rivers in the
whole country which was um interesting
to me in terms of um
statistics So within my section um
we have oversight over uh New
Hampshire's child fatality Review
Committee um in accordance with RSA
13241 uh its purpose is to conduct
comprehensive multidisciplinary reviews
on preventable deaths of children 21 and
under um in the state um the executive
committee chooses uh the deaths that we
of the child fatality Review Committee
chooses those deaths uh based on vital
records data um data uh that the state
has Hospital data um and our colleagues
at the medical examiner office a
preventable death is one in which a
reasonable intervention based on the
conditions circumstances or resources
available at the time might have
prevented the death the real purpose of
uh fatality review committees are to uh
determine recommendations and those
recommendations are medical nature um
educational social legal or uh
psychological nature they're also policy
interventions um it's the intent that
the recommendations generated by the
committee will have the potential to
prevent future deaths and are feasible
and evidence
informed often these recommendations are
centered on community-based prevention
efforts um such as the ones uh the life
jacket loer stations that my colleague
um Mr Esten uh just
described um after reviews of drowning
deaths in state fiscal year 2020 one of
the highlighted recommendations of the
committee was the support for life
jacket laner programs particularly those
on sites directly adjacent to open
bodies of water and often at popular
unsupervised recreational locations um
which is often the case um in in the
state of New Hampshire uh the
recommendations also included Waters
that are known for dangerous conditions
like the marac um but they're dangerous
because of things like depth submerged
objects and strong currents um life
jackets because of their design and
buoyancy are known um and effective
deterrence to Drowning by keeping the
airway above water when the wearer is in
the water the risk of drowning decreas
is but as much as 50% when a life jacket
is worn so it is a proven Public Health
intervention the maternal and child
health section also helps to support
efforts uh through a contract with um uh
Jim's uh employer Dartmouth Health the
injury prevention center
um and and helps to support uh Jim
forgot to tell you that I help to
support his salary uh but I do um and he
and his colleagues are the uh ta for the
life jacket uh laner programs around the
state um we fund that through Federal
title uh five maternal and child health
block grant funds through the health
resources and services um
Administration uh New Hampshire has
consistently Incorporated drowning
prevention um activities into our uh
maternal and child health uh strategic
plan so dring prevention is a very
important part of maternal and child
health uh thank you for your support of
this very important legislation I'm
happen I'm happy to answer any questions
that you may
have any questions for the
speaker representative
Lon thank you m Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um is there any
additional funds available through those
Federal lot grants that could help
expand this
program so um the title five black Grant
interesting fact is uh the oldest uh
Public Health Grant in the United States
since
1935 um it's allocated to every state
and territory based on the number of
children um living in poverty so New
Hampshire actually gets less than many
of its um surrounding uh States um that
number varies very little over the years
um uh it's actually gone down uh within
the last 10 years I'd say uh we are will
be currently or we will be entering into
A needs assessment year where we're
going to we meaning maternal and child
health uh will be doing A needs
assessment of um the state's priorities
with respect to um uh moms and kids and
so uh injury prevention has always been
in children has always been a uh
priority for us uh hopefully we'll we'll
see again for uh
2025 so the the funding is determined uh
you know by how much we have um our
other
contractors uh it's a complicated yeah
and it's like Jim said you know there
are um uh Safe Kids us say uh has uh uh
some funding but there is limited
funding with respect to uh uh drowning
prevention what' you say at this point
at this point in time yeah in injury
prevention in general there is
so does that did I answer your question
okay representative Derby thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
um if I understood you correctly um
you're you evaluate um you know injury
death prevention for um you children and
maternal Health across a wide variety of
different areas um yes are there can you
think of any analogies where um where
you have work where the maybe the
department has worked with um privately
funded um let's say uh um um privately
funded sources um for
you know for uh
donations uh to support support those
programs rather than coming to the state
or coming to the federal
government um so I'm thinking of um so a
life jacket is is like a device right so
I'm thinking of other devices that um
that so like a car passenger safety seat
right so um uh I know that New Hampshire
gets money through the office of Highway
Safety with the Department of Safety
Federal funding for child passenger
safety at Jim's shop um to purchase car
seats uh a car seat fitting events um
that also is funded by thing you know
back in the day Jim and I would do car
seat um fittings at um uh toys or us
right so like a a so yes there are um uh
other uh sort of evidence not evidence
but viice um type of interventions that
um are are have been funded and are
uh that was that also did that answer
your question follow thank you for the
followup Mr chair um so does the
department um directly engage DHHS
directly engage with these private
entities to solicit donations that way
so so so no it's very difficult um as
you know to uh uh there's a process for
accepting State funding so we accept uh
we go for and accept Federal funding
that's a long process um that includes
uh uh fiscal committee approval GNC
approval etc etc um it is rare that um
and I'm not even sure if I know of a of
a I'd have to get back to you about we
we have uh never accepted uh private
Foundation funding however um our
colleagues do none of the work that we
do um uh within MCH or public health uh
is within ourselves so uh many times we
work with community- based organizations
we know practically all of them in the
state um and then help them to uh um uh
like kind of like uh Chad you know
Children's Hospital artment to seek
donations for a specific uh
project
representative rang thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question um
during your testimony you had said
something that was said by previous
speakers about 31 deaths along the maram
river you said that also included
Massachusetts so I'm wondering how many
of those deaths were in Massachusetts
how many in New Hampshire and of those
how many were children I would have to
get back to you with that question okay
and then followup and um as far as the
the what I'm hearing you saying is that
your your work is really focused on
saving children and thank you very much
for that but the life jacket program is
that all children size life Jack no no
no um and Jim I think you have a variety
of different sizes do you want to come
fine I don't think that there are any
life uh jacket laner programs that you
have that have just um children sizes no
we provide one infant um and they're the
most expensive we provide um two 30 to
50 pound life jackets two 50 to 90 pound
life jackets um two extra small Smalls
and then two uh large medium larges and
then one extra large so we're trying to
cover um
we we know everyone's vulnerable the
children are the most vulnerable we have
five for the children but we also have
bigger kids that don't fit into the
smaller ones so they have to use you
know extra small small or something but
use representative
wealth thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my questions um is it your
expectation that somebody would use
these if they're walking along the edge
of the river or are they a uh an
emergency
PFT uh well I think uh uh Jim uh talked
about uh Safety near the river it's our
expectation that if people needed them
and they did not have them that they
would use them when going on the river
or when in the river it's my experience
that um the uh fatalities uh injuries
and um uh that are Hospital ized and
emergency department visits are those uh
and I know you had asked a question
earlier about um in the river versus or
in a body of water versus um uh just
going alongside the water right and and
most of those are in within the body of
water
so
okay I mean New Hampshire has a law for
you know for boating for for kids um uh
which the Marine Patrol does a really
great job of
enforcing and you know not for adults
Children
followup so your expectation is that
somebody
that's recreating on the edge of the
river would come and take one of these
out of the box use it and then return it
assuming that they didn't slept in the
rofer or something um
it would be our hope that if there was a
laner program there that uh yes they
they could uh take it and and use it and
I think as Mr um Esten uh explained you
know uh the issue was with you know
people bringing it back but um but if if
uh they do not have one then um
yes thank
you any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you very much I don't
have any new or other pink cards is
there anyone else to speak on hb1
1440 I'll ask again anyone else to speak
on hb1
1440 seeing no one approaching the mic
I'll close the hearing on hb1
1440 we'll start the hearing on HB
you
oh
sponsor representative
McGee
welcome thank you very much and thank
you uh Mr chair and members of resource
Recreation and
development
um I'm representative cat McGee and from
Hillsboro 35 which is Hollis and I thank
you for consideration of 1483 today a
bill allowing local regulation of water
supply concerning
subdivisions I'd like to give you just a
brief history of how this bill came
about and also describe my perspective
on the problem the bill aims to
fix as you can see from the sponsor list
before you the bill is a bipartisan
effort two years ago a constituent in
Hollis at the transfer station uh
decided to tell me his major concern
with development going on in our town uh
and in general and he said water is a
precious resource resource and we take
it for granted when uh development goes
in there is very little consideration
given to the impact of that new series
of uh private Wells on local water
supply and any potential adverse effects
to surrounding even Downstream if you
will existing
homes I took my constituents concerns to
heart and as a member of my local zoning
board I did a little digging with the
town planner and talked with Dees water
folks and tried to figure out an
appropriate legislative
response as you know many bills do not
make it through on the first uh attempt
through the legislative
Gauntlet uh and this bill was no
exception to that uh what you have
before you today is a revised version of
last year's HB 310 which required
developers of subdivisions of over four
houses to provide a hydrology study for
water adequacy and
portability there were many eyes on HB
310 and that resulted in some very good
input I was on medical leave when the
bill was actually heard and it was ited
at that time so this is the improved
version which seeks to protect home
buyers and municipalities from
supporting Housing Development that does
not adequately consider the critical
needs of water uh right at the
outset the bill um exempts Community
water systems and large groundwater
withdrawals because the prior version
was too broad in that regard in this
bill we put the ownership on local
Planning and Zoning rather than trying
to mandate a one-size fits-all approach
but we want to change the L we wanted to
change the language in order to bring a
focus to water as an essential aspect of
housing just as we cannot sell a house
without a septic permit local planners
should be able to require that housing
is not being built without adequate or
usable Water Supplies this bill ensures
that a resource that receives cursory
consideration be elevated to a greater
scrutiny and uh at the very time when we
are being asked to rapidly build more
housing stock hb1
1483 asks planning boards to prescribe
minimum on lot private well testing
requirements to assure adequate water
supply for subdivisions as defined in
RSA 674 colon
362 this assures that there is Clarity
between the municipality and the
developer at the outset of what is
needed um to support new
builds with adequate water
and minimum disruption to existing
Neighbors on private Wells I think my
constituent was spoton in bringing uh um
I lost my place in bringing this to to
our attention homeowners and home buyers
deserve the peace of mind this
legislation can provide experienced
legislators know that you cannot fix
every situation with a change in statute
but this is an area where we can improve
the focus on water in building
subdivisions finally the bill language
includes the ability of the planning
board to assess the costs of notice to
abutters and administrative expenses to
the developer for meeting this
requirement at their discretion which
helps fund the local control piece of
what we uh used to call a warranty of
mercant
tability
um as
your uh it's as close as to a warranty
of Mer ability as you're going to get um
so people will be able to understand
that they're going to get what they're
paying for and um if you build a a
neighborhood of houses and then owners
find out that they have to limit their
water use to certain hours of the day or
the quality of the water is such that
they have to mitigate it to use it
somebody's really been sold a lemon so I
believe that the New Hampshire Municipal
Association and also the um Department
of environment Services Water Division
are going to be speaking on behalf of
the bill as well um and I just want to
explain also that this bill comes back
to you as enabling legislation so it's
it's helping local municipalities to be
able to focus on this issue with the
change in the statute but it doesn't
require them to do anything specifically
so what it's doing is really trying to
elevate the issue so that they have a
tool in their hand when a developer
comes in and and goes to goes to build
build uh a subdivision that's
it take questions I'm happy to take
questions yes are there any questions
for the prime
sponsor representative
run thank you very much Mr chair and
thank you representative for taking my
question I remember my first term in the
house we had a bill I believe
representative Hobson who was on the
committee had sponsored it regarding
this issue and then I remember we
hearing our your bill last um time so
I'm really glad that you address some of
the issues where this is putting more of
the um responsibility I guess on the
town their municipality and their
planning board have you had discussions
with the planning board in Hollis or
anybody in that realm to see what they
think of this I have I I mean our town
planner Kevin Anderson is the really um
was the point person and he also attends
the zoning board meetings and I'm on the
zoning board so I made the zoning board
aware and the chair of the zone this
chair of the planning board is also on
the zoning board so I've actually talked
to quite a few people that this would
affect in my town and they're all in
favor of it they think it's a good idea
thank y thank you any other
montain thank you thank you for taking
my question so just to be clear I'm sort
of remembering
h310 um so you remove the hydrology
specifically like having to do that
study um yeah I mean it was considered a
mandate because the way it was written
it would require it and depending on the
project um and depending on the planning
board a hydrology study may or may not
be part of that project and so it was um
deemed as not necessary to be put into
the
statute and follow up so y sure so
you're just trying to keep the the
wording um minimum on lot private well
testing requirements to
be um do you care to elaborate on what
you think that might be yes I I think
when folks go to build an individual
house you have perk testing so you and
you know so you determine whether or not
you are have suitable amount of water to
support a well this is um an attempt to
put into the statute language that would
allow those people who are responsible
for planning when a subdivision is going
in so more houses than one house to look
at it in an overall way and so the idea
is just to um support that in the
language and um because it hasn't been
supported in the past in the statutory
language so we have the individual perk
test for an individual home and then we
have an expensive hydrology report which
isn't required but can be done if you
think that there may be issues this is
sort of serving that interim situation
where you now have it elevated so that
it should be looked at in terms of um uh
sort of proofs that you can bring back
to the Planters in the town that uh
there's going to be adequate water for
not only the houses you're putting in
but also for the surrounding private
Wells because that has been an issue in
some of the subdivisions that have been
put in that as we were doing research
that was one of the things that came to
light is that water is starting to
become an issue um that needs greater
scrutiny I think it's also a very
difficult issue to solve or to address
through legislation and so I saw the
letter that came from from water
services at Dees saying that there was a
a Water Commission in '08 that put out a
report in 2010 and they uh came to some
similar conclusions that there ought to
be something something additional at the
municipal level but they didn't follow
through with legislation that actually
got there and I was happy to see the
letter said that they felt that this
bill was consistent with what they were
trying to get at so I I really just see
it as enabling rather than
mandating thank you you're
welcome sentive Derby thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my
question I'm sorry for the redundant
question here but I just want to make
sure I get this you're talking about um
subdivisions where there's going to be
basically uh Wells per home as opposed
to some kind of um water source that's
shared by all the homes in the
subdivision that's what you're trying to
enable allow the municipalities to sort
of monitor the water impact of I think
thank you for the question um I think
that uh in my town the majority of
subdivisions that have been put in have
not had um um have not had water sources
sized for the entire group of buildings
they've been individual Wells and I
think that happens in many towns in New
Hampshire um this doesn't specify
um that either of those is exclusionary
to the other in other words it doesn't
matter what type of system you're
putting in if you're putting in houses
then you um have to basically show that
there's adequate Supply so I I don't
think it's about individual Wells or
Collective Wells I know we do have some
housing um we have some senior housing
where uh I got a call on Thanksgiving
that they were out of water and it's
happened more than once you know so it
it would cover that type of a situation
as well where there was a well that was
being used by multiple uh residences in
a building or buildings so it doesn't
specify specifically so that it can be
applied to different types of uh
projects Pro s you're welcome any other
questions I I have a question the last
paragraph of the bill talks about
planning boards charging notification
fees and other fees to the
applicant I I could be mistaken but I
believe in my town could could you not
under the current
statutes uh include the notification fee
and your filing fee and then regarding
the other
testing I know that my town makes the
applicant pay for a t a town review by
its engineer so could they not now under
carrent law ask them to do a water test
and submit it thank you that's it's a
good very good question I believe and
maybe someone else can um can speak to
this I believe that this language was
added to this uh section of the
statute so it would apply specifically
to this process um I I uh am aware
that uh applicants are required to cover
a butter notifications on the zoning
board I've been on the zoning board for
years so that is true um I'm sure there
is a statute that already covers that
but I think the additional language
around providing assessment of
reasonable fees to cover the board's
administrative expenses and costs of
special
investigation
again I think they wanted the the
language reiterated to go along with
this
statute um so that when this was what
you were undertaking this piece of it
you would be able to recover those fees
they wanted it to be explicit I guess
rather than uh implicit so that's the
best I can answer that I'm not really
sure I think you can probably you can
probably charge people for those
administrative fees or engineering fees
um but I think they just wanted it to go
along with with the language for this
particular section thank you any other
questions for the prime sponsor seeing
none thank you thank you appreciate you
being
here uh I have a pink card uh from
Dees
good afternoon I'm Brandon kernin
administrator of the drinking water and
groundwater Bureau at
Dees um our agency at this point is
notes at HB 1483 is not proposing the
change the statutes relative to anything
that Dees regulates nor does it propose
to re regulate and overlap with anything
we regulate like Community water systems
or large groundw withdrawals and because
the bill is focused on municipal
authorities were not taking a position
on the bill but I would like to provide
some information very quickly on it um
this bill would clarify that
municipalities can address the adequacy
of water supply when they're looking at
a proposed subdivision um some
municipalities have done this already
under existing statute but this would
make it explicit really clear that
municipalities may do this if they want
to they don't have to when they look at
a
subdivision um and it also makes it
clear that it won't interfere with our
assessment of adequacy of water supply
when we look at it for large groundwater
draws and Community water systems and so
we think that's a really good aspect of
the bill essentially what this bill is
doing it's allowing municipalities to
look at the adequacy of water supply
where Dees is not right now and so some
degree that makes a lot of sense as the
legislative commission identified back
in
2010 and the bill also as you just
discussed would clarify that
municipality that's doing this work can
recoup costs um associated with it
because they probably will need
technical assistance from an outside
consultant to look at the type of data
that they would be um provided if they
did develop these
regulations as was mentioned earlier and
also in our letter of testimony there
was a groundwater commission that the
legislature convened from 2003 to
2010 that looked at a lot of issues and
did look at this issue and wrote a
report on it the commission felt the
report was complete you know identifying
the areas of law where we're not
addressing water supply adequacy you
know that's the areas um addressed by
House Bill
1483 but the commission had a lot of
people on it over 20 people anything
anybody from representing municipalities
Senators representatives to business and
industry ski industry Agriculture and so
while everyone agreed the report was
complete and the fact and the facts of
the report were accurate there was
disagreement on if there was a need for
an increased Municipal role in
regulating groundwater withdrawal so
they didn't come up with a final
recommendation there they just accepted
the report as a essentially a technical
resource and if anyone's interested in
that report um I did bring copies of
just the parts of the report that
address this issue including some model
regulations that a municipality could
adopt if if they wanted to perhaps now
under existing statute but certainly if
this bill was passed where it explicitly
addresses Municipal regulation at the
subdivision level I'd be happy to share
those with you the model regulations are
not Dees recommendations they're not
Dees products they are the work of a
commission obviously myself and my
colleague Steve Roy did a lot of the leg
work for it but I just want to clarify
they're not necessarily documents that
we're promoting right now but they are
good
resources um the documents are 14 years
old so some of the internet links are
broken in it as well but there's still a
lot of good information there may be
happy to answer any
questions any questions for the
speaker representative Darby thank you
Mr chair thank you um Mr K I taking my
question just to similar to the question
I asked um representative
McGee um the um Community Water
Systems I we just looked up the rule it
seems like it's when it's 15 houses
that's what makes it a community water
system and every so this would be
subdivisions like they could have a
large well if it's 10 houses and it's
not considered a community water system
if it's serving less than 25 people 25
okay thank you very much more than six
months a
year any other
questions representative Ron thank you
Mr chair thank you Mr Kel for taking my
question just a follow up on um
representative Darby's question you're
look when you when um there is a DS is
looking at a large community withdrawal
pro project they're looking at number of
homes or number of bedrooms because
septic systems are a number of
bedrooms it it can be a a feature of the
development you know if it's a apartment
complex that has a certain number of
bedrooms then we would apply a certain
per capita to that to calculate it if
it's a standalone House housing that has
certain number of bedrooms we would look
at that as well so it's kind of site
specific and you know we cann't work
with the we work with the applicant to
really pin down what is the problem
population served of a given development
okay so so it is more populationbased
not just unit based okay thank you but
certainly units are a Sur good of
population
so any other
question seeing none thank you for your
testimony my last pink card natch graay
Bill thank you Mr chair n Grace for the
municipal Association uh we do support
this legislation I just want to make
clear that this isn't a problem isolated
to Hollis um and doing research uh and
advance for the legislation I'm aware
that the municipalities of Auburn
Northampton Raymond Rochester and Windam
have all um gone through approval
processes for subdivisions where it
turns out either the water supply was
inadequate for the originally planned
number of units or uh the water itself
was not um in a condition that it was
treatable so it was had a high degree of
iron and manganese or or other
contaminants in it um one of the things
that we believe that this will do is
move the
conversation um kind of the as a local
option on the front side of um housing
housing and other development for the
adequacy of water um whereas it's
currently exists on the on the backs
side so you often see people come before
the planning board go through that whole
process and then once they you know
basically receive that local approval or
pretty close to it that's when they go
to Dees to receive um approval for the
wells and that's when they discover
there's a problem with the water so
there's a lot of time effort and money
uh put into projects which simply can't
get off the ground because most people
are not going to buy properties that
don't have a water supply um so as
mentioned previous viously this is is a
local option I would assume it would be
of most interest in those communities
where there are known water issues and
of course we would work closely with
Dees to um help provide those
communities any sort of model guidance
that may be helpful um should this
legislation pass and I'm happy to uh
answer any questions the commune may
have any questions representative Darby
um thanks thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question we need to talk
about known water issues I didn't pick
this up earlier but might you think
about for example pasas in groundwater
as as something that could be regulated
um and tested for I think that's a known
issue um there are certain communities
in the state that are affected by pasas
and obviously other contaminants um one
of the questions certainly of for new
development going in uh and existing
development is where that contamination
is um and that's certainly a question I
would assume that most people would be
interested in who are looking to build
in those
communities any other
questions I have a technical question
now you can't leave yet sure um since I
know you're an attorney um you mentioned
going from the back side to the front
side so under current law and statutes
can the planning board now with going
through the normal process of amending
the planning board regulations and
Zoning pass a law that does what this
bill
suggests so it's not currently expressed
in 674 36 which contains a long list of
things that um subdivision regulations
may
do because of that I
would suggest that the legislature
consider adding this to the list just to
make it very clear that this is
something that they may do um that
avoids is having to have any sort of
Court battles over
it thank you thank you any other uh
representative Derby for a followup
thank you Mr chair thanks again for
taking my question I only um just
scanning through it again I only see
testing with respect to uh water supply
um and water quantity as opposed to
water quality you know we had a bill
last year about um mandatory testing for
new wells and that doesn't seem to be
this doesn't seem to be cover and that
was pretty contentious um this doesn't
seem to cover that it just seems to be
Supply so am I missing
something uh I don't think so I think um
maybe I misspoke earlier um with the
quantity issue
um obviously one of the questions that
that I think that we would have
with
um the the quantity is that we we want
to make sure that there actually is
water present um but the quality issue
comes into that because um if you have a
low water quantity and I think this
might be a more appropriate question for
for um Mr kernin uh to answer but if you
have certain indicators with water
quantity um that may indicate that there
is some sort of contaminant there I mean
that may not be the case with past but
it may be the case with something like
manganese or or iron but I'm not the
me
another representative Darby asked that
I'll have a follow up um before they can
get a bu occupancy permit in town
wouldn't the water have to be tested and
proved portable to answer the quality
question yes I believe so thank you any
other
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you and I don't have any
other pink cards so I'll ask twice
anyone else to testify on hb14
83 anyone else ATT test to I am 1483
seeing no one approaching the mic I'll
close the hearing on HB
1483 thank you very
chair